Donald Trump is back ladies and
gentlemen the man is back he is on
Facebook he is on YouTube he has posted
officially and there's some rumors that
he may be returning to Twitter as well
soon we will see it's hard to know for
sure so we're gonna talk about that and
uh as you may have noticed it's St
Patrick's Day so we had a special title
card today and uh so we're gonna have a
good relaxing time we also got to talk
about because St Patrick's Day Joe Biden
who said that he's not really Irish
because he doesn't have any family
member because he's sober and his family
members aren't in jail which I find
highly offensive as a Persian person who
is part Irish Joe Biden has no right to
insult my people that being said Sheamus
everybody
well said that's a that's actually a
really good point Sheamus it is very
offensive to make stereotypical jokes
about Irish people in that way as an
Irish person myself I am deeply offended
by what Joe Biden has said yeah and
potato jokes stuff like that I know yeah
so uh thanks for hanging out Sheamus of
Freedom Tunes you know we missed you and
we're glad that you're back but joining
us in actuality is uh Jenny tear
you want to introduce yourself thank you
hi Jenny Taylor with the Daily Caller
news Foundation I'm a reporter who
covers immigration and the Border
right on thanks for hanging out should
be uh relaxing Friday I suppose
Phil potatoes a tough fact to follow I
know I am uh Phil Labonte lead singer of
All That Remains uh anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary and if you didn't
know I'm Ian Crossland that's a sweet
potato it's blasphemy it's not even a
real potato
it's a potato I like them better it's a
different kind of potato Jenny you said
you were on both borders this is a crazy
story I mean I'm sure you've got so much
to talk about we'll talk about on the
show it's great to see you you follow me
anywhere but let's get to it Kellen we
got what's up hey what's up everybody
happy St Patrick's Day it's Kellen um
quick note uh Discord is up and running
so you can hop in there right now
um when you know if you're a member on
timcast.com you get access to the
Discord so just quick reminder yes go to
timcast.com let's pull that up right
here yes sir and then you click that
join us button on the website you'll
also notice there's a Discord button now
right there on the left you can see I'm
highlighting it and when you go to that
it will give you the instructions on how
to sign up for the Discord server which
is a chat program you can hang out with
other other members of the website and
we reopened chat for everybody because
now members are it's all Consolidated so
the main issue was we had people who
were like hey there's no real way to
chat when the show's going live because
the chat goes crazy and so we were like
let's try a members only chat to see if
that works and a lot of people were like
this is awesome but there are a lot of
people who didn't want to become members
or people who are already members at
timcast.com like I don't want to sign up
twice so we decided Well we want to
launch a Discord so now if you're a
member at timcast you get access to the
members only chat room which we should
have up and running on our end
Monday so that for the members on the
uncensored shows we can take in a call
from the uh from the members from you
guys and there are varying tiers we've
set up you can check that out and like a
VIP Club if you want to be in that where
we'll have uh Tim cast crew members and
other such people hanging out and the
other thing I'll say is uh I've got
Wicked food poisoning I am very sick so
I may just like sit here drooling on
myself while Phil Ian and Jenny talk
about everything but uh I I didn't want
to uh I don't want the show to get
canceled but honestly like after we
filmed the culture War podcast this
morning I just went to sleep and I woke
up at like 6 30 and they were like are
we doing the show or not I'm like I'm
coming you know it's just I eat some
yoga I still care as yogurt I had to do
it that's fine it had to be done the
aloe also if you want to drink a shot
that'll do it probably a good thing so
anyway we're here and we're going to
talk about a lot of fun stuff and it's
good that we are because Donald Trump is
back here's the first story that we got
timgas.com Trump's YouTube has been
restored posts first video in two years
this channel will continue to be subject
to our policies just like any other
channel ladies and gentlemen let me just
scroll right down here is the video from
Donald J Trump sorry to keep you
awaiting complicated business
complicated
that was it sorry to keep you waiting
complicated business complicated four
seconds four seconds of Donald Trump
posted it's got 115 000 views and then
the other big news that Trump is back on
Facebook he posts for the first time on
Facebook since January 6 2021 and I
think he just posted in big capital
letters I'm back I think that's what it
was you know someone mentioned that the
mistake he's been making lately is that
he's still in 2015 Underdog mindset I
think it's Patrick Bet David and that
he's now he's like the favorite so he
doesn't he needs to use different
tactics I think if he just started doing
short YouTube videos of like I love you
you're gonna do great in life simple
like basic he should eat a taco bowl
yeah you know eat the common food speak
to the common man but just give them
short bursts of positive energy that's
all he needs to do to start rolling
right now I'm not gonna be happy till
he's back on Twitter calling Rosie
O'Donnell fat I'm not like I'm not gonna
I mean until he's doing it didn't he say
something about starting a a women's a
WNBA team of men
I should fact check that please do
and if it's true Donald please please do
please do maybe he didn't say that
somebody I someone told me that he said
that maybe maybe not I don't know or
it's all very topical I was just
watching this interview with Michael
malice and Patrick Beth David on
valuetainment we talked about a little
bit before the show he uh and they were
talking about truth social the valuation
of the company has dipped apparently I
haven't been able to verify this but
they were both talking about it too it's
like worth half of what it was worth and
that they're like why hasn't he been on
Twitter well Patrick surmised that it's
probably because he's trying to get make
sure people keep coming to his website
to pay back his investors with Trump uh
the company that owns truth social uh
that SPAC that they did and then is that
dwac his dwac I'm not sure I'm not sure
but um that and they're like maybe if
true Soldier because they were like it's
true social about to crumble like is it
falling apart are they about to close it
down and if it does is that good for
Trump and then they were arguing whether
it is or not some people like it'll free
them up he doesn't have to please his
past investors anymore he can go do
whatever he wants again I mean it's it's
down quite a bit
but uh that's only because when it
started it spiked and then I think dwack
reached like a hundred bucks a share
March 2020
around March of 2022 what is this
Trump's not as simple without the
audience like Trump is like Trump isn't
Trump's you know Trump can say stuff on
Truth social but he's not like when he's
preaching to his own crowd it's not as
funny as when he's on Twitter with like
reply guys going at it and you know
saying things to get people worked up
because half the fun of trump on Twitter
was reading the replies and watching
people you know make videos and stuff so
I'm not I'm not I'm not going to be
happy until he's fully restored to
Twitter you consider yourself political
Johnny are you just great news I'm
pretty straight I think also like
Trump's Twitter like you were saying
like it drove the news cycle like I
don't think truth social when he posts
on there it does that at all nobody
cares I think you need an account to
even read stuff it's crazy yeah you got
it you need to be at least publicly able
to be read if you want to be part of the
news cycle
the great thing about Trump was call
FeFe oh that's you're not getting that
with him posting your true social I'm
actually offended they won't tell us
what really happened well I wasn't we
had cash Patel here and he was like I
know what happened but I'm not telling
you and it's like dude how dare you we
must know the secrets of coffee he also
said that like only like it was only
like two people that actually knew and
I'm I'm dubious about whether anyone
knows at all somebody sausage fingered
the phone yeah they were yeah whoops I
sent it and then they were like whatever
another point that they were making
about the problems that true social may
be having it's tough to tell because
like you said there's a spike in the
beginning is that Elon Musk bought
Twitter and the whole point of true
social is we're gonna make a free speech
social network so he did it he set it up
they got investment they got it going
and then Elon bought Twitter and was
like now Twitter's a free speech social
network and everyone was like well
what's the point of Truth Now it also
really re like right away truth social
turned into the right wing so it wasn't
it wasn't just like the Free Speech
alternative it was so heavily part
Artisan that it became the antithesis to
Twitter so Twitter is where all the
left-leaning people were for a long time
so until musk look at Mastodon well
that's what happened with it yeah who
talks about Mastodon there's still some
people out there on Twitter they're
really committed leftists and their
people are committed to truth but
doesn't matter it's not in the
conversation no no it's not at all it's
not at all partisan social media is not
the way social media is supposed to be a
neutral ground I mean I think the best
social media has not been a neutral
offering where people can go at it if
they want or they can like communicate
it's hard if someone's like blocking a
certain type of person it's terrible and
you know the thing like there's a lot of
people that that when musk bought
Twitter they were they were upset that
it wasn't a pure Free Speech uh platform
and I don't think that there was ever
gonna be I think that that was a mistake
to think that it was ever going to be
purely Free Speech where like you know
you you were never going to have Twitter
turned into 4chan's B board you know
what I mean it was never going to be you
know a Chan board or whatever um but
with musk there aren't ideas that are
repressed in the same way that ideas
were repressed when you know the
previous owners had Twitter because the
you know all the stuff with that's
coming out now about the about you know
whether it be the administration or
whether it be uh covid stuff and and
stuff with fauci or you know where where
covet came from it's Etc that stuff
would have been heavily suppressed had
the ownership still been the previous
owners I think that and I don't think
there's a lot of art I don't think
there's a lot of substance to arguments
against that perspective yeah I agree
did you were you thinking something I
mean I think like
as weird as it sounds I think like the
minute Elon took over
Twitter I was like holy crap all of the
DMs like in my spam DMS it was like so
many weird people that came through
which I guess is like a side effect of
having to like open up the entire space
but it was weird to see more interaction
that way more interaction and like
comments on things I think it really did
like open up what you know maybe people
consider Shadow Banning or you know
suppression of different accounts like I
think it really did change like
automatically I could tell and there was
like a week after he bought it I think
all a bunch of subscribers were lost and
gained by different accounts all at once
a lot of stuff what's that leftists were
losing followers like crazy and the
right was gaining I gained a huge chunk
I gained like well that means you're far
right you know seven percent of my or
one percent or something increased but
there was a large increase yeah that
proves it guarantees lock them up um
he said today he's going to be open
sourcing uh open source all code used to
recommend tweets on March 31st last week
from about five o'clock today that's
gonna be like there's going to be a code
in there that says like if Donald Trump
equals yes then promote equals no yeah
I'm not even kidding I mean like
obviously he's got rid of that stuff but
we'll probably see some some stuff like
that that he didn't do that's fine yeah
he threads on and says that it's going
to be embarrassing for for him and for
Twitter for this stuff to be brought on
there because the code is so horribly
done he's just been complaining about it
for months but he said you know that's
the first step you it's the humility you
acknowledge how crappy it is and then
the community starts building it and
fixing it and contributing it's going to
be great this is the first step it's not
this doesn't mean he's open sourcing
everything in fact Minds reply the open
source organism will self-organize into
something powerful this is the way Bill
talks yeah for sure to the social media
organisms open source organism will
self-organize into something powerful I
was like did you misspeak do you mean
Organization no that's how Bill talks he
thinks of social media as a living
organism in the universe and stuff he
talks about it like it's an organized
demon Maybe
sometimes the Borg Tick Tock is for sure
yeah creepy man it just ruined me
I'm a victim yes how often are you on
Tick Tock
um every morning every night it's the
only way I survive honestly really oh
yeah what do you what are you watching
my brain you watch like and we just talk
about cutting their junk off or
something no no I'm not on that
algorithm I'm like on the like
influencer like you know girl who lives
in New York I'm on the cooking tick
tocks I'm on the Travel tick tocks the
chocolate dude the chocolate maker dude
dude there's this dude that makes
chocolate and like he'll make like he
made a velociraptor out of chocolate and
he made like like a crane arm thing out
of chocolate and it's like crazy crazy
stuff and people in the chat you know
who I'm talking about when I talk about
the chocolate kind I like the uh the
workout tick tocks because I'm I'm
trying to get my figure better so I have
to watch these women you know in yoga
pants all the time
it's completely ridiculous they do this
is this uh Omri gushon that I don't know
his name so when when you're on Tick
Tock is it like do you notice the
algorithm feet trying to feed you things
to get you to go down different paths oh
yeah absolutely and the problem is that
when you're in Social settings after you
like watch Tick Tock so much and you're
so addicted like you're always looking
for like that quick hit of dopamine and
you're not getting it in normal social
settings like you would on Tick Tock so
you're always like I'm so bored and like
I've cut myself off it's horrible and it
happens to a lot of people I'm pretty
sure like girls were getting like ticks
from Tick Tock that was a big story they
started twitching because they because
the algorithm would feed them videos of
women with Tourette's and then they
would watch these videos endlessly a
woman ticking and then they would start
developing ticks this is the crazy thing
when I saw a story like that I was like
maybe maybe women are more susceptible
to social engineering than men I mean I
think I shouldn't say maybe I think it's
factually true so the fact that women
can generate a fake Social Tourette's
says a lot about what social media is
doing to the fabric of society and I
don't think you can have the 19th
Amendment and social media at the same
time ah yeah I think we should keep the
knife
like oh no way no way social media is
way more jokes AI is better than law You
could argue that like no amount of
copyright law can catch up with the
amount of AI advancement that thing's
just completely obliterating the 1500s
law of can't share my thing like it
takes pictures from all over the
internet that are all copywritten a
bunch of them are and then it just feeds
you like totally violates copyright law
but there's no way to stop it yeah I
gotta say though about the 19th
Amendment
now that I'm like sick and don't care
all that much
because I feel like crap I don't care
what these liberal Lefty women think
about about me or My Views anyway you
know so if like all the conservative
women are coming on this show and being
like yes we should repeal the 19th I'm
just gonna be like okay I guess like I'm
not going to Pander to these leftist
cult members they don't mean anything to
me but then like what am I supposed to
do tell the conservative women they're
wrong because like hey all these women
are saying this thing but you're wrong
it's like well either respect their
agency as women who want to repeal the
19th through their own Vote or I don't
so if I'm going to respect them as women
and the right to choose and make
political decisions their decision would
be to give up their right to vote I mean
personally I don't I think that there
isn't uh there is something to the
argument that people need to have skin
in the game uh if they're voting so you
have to have you know just being able to
vote for the government to give you you
know whatever kind of benefits or
whatever uh you know that's not fair to
the yes service guarantee citizenship
exactly you know so I agree I don't
think that I don't think that it should
be just based on gender like I don't
know I don't I understand the arguments
of even making and the arguments about
you know generally women are more
emotional and blah blah I understand
that but I still don't think that it
should be based on gender but I do think
that there is an argument to be made
that you know and it which is the same
argument that's been you know been for a
long time the reason why men had the had
the vote and women didn't is men were
were responsible for the women so if a
woman went out and did something that
was wrong men would get punished so like
if a woman destroyed a man you know
someone else or something men would end
up being you know would have to be
responsible for bigger issue is that men
were drafted for war and drafted for the
fire brigade sure and the idea was if
you are here to volunteer for the
community then you have a right to vote
and then women advocated for the
suffragette said we shouldn't have to do
anything and we should get the right to
vote anyway and they're like okay
but that's that you know that makes no
sense I think civil responsibility I
don't think the suffragettes were making
that argument I think they were because
the argue there were no that was a big
component of I was reading a bunch about
uh
the the fire brigade was a big issue for
the women who opposed the uh women's
suffrage specifically I can't remember
the one's name but the the opponents of
women's suffrage said outright I don't
want to be drafted yes or forced to join
the fire brigade yeah okay the argument
was I don't want the Civil
responsibilities that come with voting
that's for men to do and then the
suffragettes were like we should get
those anyway regardless of civil
responsibilities so the compromise was
made when passing the 19th amendment
that women would be exempt from fire
brigade and exempts and because that was
the argument from the anti-suffragettes
they were like okay well how about this
we don't require any civic duty and you
get to vote anyway and they're like well
now we have no argument what are your
thoughts Jenny you're a woman I want to
know I mean women gave birth to all
these men making the decisions and to
all the soldiers that were fighting
um you know and a lot of them in Wartime
did step up and Aid these soldiers and
you know helped in different ways I mean
I believe I should have the right to
vote I believe women should have the
right to vote
cozy the Riveter that Meme of the girl
doing this because she was building the
bombs in the factories every girl on
Halloween now dresses like that right
yeah the issue that these conservative
women often bring up I'm I'm more like I
don't know man like I'm not a woman so
I'm not gonna but like conservative
women are very much anti-19th and
liberal are pro-it but the majority of
millennial women 70 are Democrats and
they just vote for this stuff whether
there's policy that makes sense anyway
so if only women voted you'd have
Democrat presidents and if only men
voted you'd have Republican presidents
so the the main issue I think is not so
much whether it's an issue of uh women
voting and women have right to vote it's
an issue of men and women statistically
vote in different ways that rip the
country apart totally well right now
it's abortion is the biggest thing for
women that are my age right like yeah
but I don't I I think that's actually a
good example of women don't vote for
things they vote for feelings and so
like
the fact that
it could be abortion today or anything
else tomorrow the fact that the woke
left seemingly has no cohesive ideology
and they vote for whatever the stuff is
regardless I think is an is an element
of gender-based voting biases I was just
checking it out and it's 1912. uh what
is it 1920 is when it was ratified uh
it's right around one radio picked up
again how this technology is changing us
as a species like radio gave us the
opportunity to listen to ourselves from
a distance like literally listen to
yourself it was the first time in
history you could record it with a
phonograph really well they're recording
happened a long time ago the phonograph
I think was the first instance of it
Thomas Edison it's pretty interesting
watching him build that thing he built
it on a roll of paper and it's like
these different rivets on the paper and
then it would like pluck the thing and
then recreate the sound of the stitching
that's pretty fascinating but I think I
mean I think it's like women maybe are
more psychological than men men are more
like brute like minimalistic women are
subject oriented men are object oriented
and then so the sub being able to
witness ourselves through radio allowed
women to become much more you know
socially cognizant perhaps which is why
this all kicked off in the early 1900s
late 18th 1878s when it started I think
I don't I understand that that or I do
agree that you you know radio did have a
big effect on society but I don't think
that I think that the seeds were planted
um before radio became normal because
when the radio became ubiquitous right
in what the 30s was it
ah let's find out I know Tesla was
working on it in the early 1900s
and by ubiquitous I mean you know we're
like most most people had a radio in
their home or something it was invented
in 1890s uh looking to see how when it
became like everyone has a radio kind of
thing yeah I mean so yeah I mean like I
said I think that I think that radio and
and stuff like that did have an effect
but the ideas you know the ideas tend to
come from philosophers and stuff like
that so the the ideas that of of human
beings being equal those ideas had been
set into motion a hundred years before
the radio I I I disagree I agree with
Ian
um there's a lot of philosophies there's
a lot of ideas they don't all rise to
the top they don't all become prominent
I think happens with radio is you've got
a radio station and they're thinking
like how many listeners can we get to
this radio station this new thing and so
they start making radio broadcasts and
they're like hey hey guy you did some
broadcast about Catholicism and the
Protestants are pissed don't do that
we're losing money and they went whoa
really and so if you're trying to
maximize the size of your audience you
are heading towards a woke Direction has
nothing to do with literature or
philosophy all that matters is who how
can we offend the least amount of people
so if you look at what's happening today
with the further attack the the the
expansion of the flow of information the
issue is quite simply conservatives
don't do anything liberals do so a
business is looking at Netflix and
there's like some story right now what
was it uh oh yeah we got some story we
can talk about I don't know if I've
pulled up oh I do actually have it right
here let's pull this up so this is from
the Federalist Kellogg pledged 91
million dollars to racial division while
slashing and employee benefits how
psychotic is that well what happened was
apparently activists started complaining
that you know snap crackle and pop or
whatever white and so the business sits
done and they say listen
what's happening well we got a thousand
emails from these angry liberals
complaining about White characters on
our cereal boxes okay what are
conservatives saying nothing they don't
care well okay then we need to discreet
give the squeaky wheel the grease when
every company does that over a hundred
years keeps giving the squeaky wheel to
Greece or trying to just minimize anger
it is going to skew in the direction we
are seeing it skew regardless of what
anyone writes about it do you think that
corporations are inherently woke having
their primary motive be
profit yes it's simple you've got a
million people in a city and Facebook
says we want 1 million members to join
Facebook well uh oh 200 000 are refusing
because there is Trump trumps on the
platform Trump supporters aren't saying
anything they don't care all right we'll
ban Trump then well now we lost a few
thousand we lost 50 000 we made two
hundred thousand so we're good that's
basically what's happening they don't
think the negative cons it's cost
benefit analysis if the cost of banning
Trump is greater than the cost of not
betting them they wouldn't do it but
because they know look people are
quitting look at uh uh Will Wheaton he's
like I'll quit Twitter unless you ban
Alex Jones and then Twitter's like oh
what do we do we're getting all these
liberals to quit oh geez oh boy we got
to do something and then of course all
social media bans Alex Jones because the
collective left threatened and the
collective left does typically uh follow
through on this stuff I I kind of agree
that uh prioritizing profit and larger
audiences is a bit leads you towards
like you know capitulating to whatever
it is of the day but then what about ESG
because they've essentially said we
don't care how many people are here
anymore we want this thing to happen so
we're going to spend your money on it
Dan be the consequences damn be the
losses it's the same thing it's they get
complaints and left and no one on the
right says anything people on the right
are like well I'm scared I'll lose my
job it's like well okay there you go
that indicates that corporations being
having a woke mindset of profit over
everything else will lead them to a
place where they eventually
do whatever the mob tells them to do yes
yes they become so accustomed to doing
what the mob wants for profit that they
continue to do what the mob wants even
if it's unprofitable until it implodes
well what about like what's happening in
Silicon Valley like all these tech
companies laying off people you have to
believe that some of them are like the
diversity equity and inclusion that's
right like oh yeah yep Microsoft just
laid off his artificial intelligence
ethics team or something that was funny
that was hilarious as they're unleashing
chat gpt4 which is giving it you see the
guy he made a Twitter Thread about
giving it money yeah he's like he's like
I set a budget and told it to make money
for me and then it worked and he's like
he's mostly getting investors right now
but like he's doing whatever Chet tells
him to do but anyway these companies are
they they are they're soulless entities
that just do whatever they think will
maximize their profits and if the left
will threaten a boycott and follow
through then you have to do what the
left says you may lose 10 of your
audience because they're conservative
but you'd lose 30 of your audience
because every liberal would quit and
conservatives don't care and it stresses
out the employees when people complain
which is another cost to your company we
are seeing Netflix recoil because the
woke stuff actually caused a massive
backlash because they reach I think what
happened is they reached the point where
they chased the dragon too far and now
the weird crackpot you know interracial
gay movies they're making are causing
people to cancel because they don't want
to watch it and now Netflix is like whoa
whoa we're actually losing money so the
cost risk analysis has reached the
Tipping Point there was a movie on um
shutter called the spiral
and uh the stupidest move I've ever seen
it's about an interracial gay couple
with an adopted daughter they move next
to a white waspy family and uh spoiler
alert everybody because I doubt you're
gonna watch it anyway the white waspy
family are uh
Immortal because they kill marginalized
people to like give give themselves
immortality and I'm just like this is
what happens this is your brain on drugs
right these companies are like look
these what the left is they're yelling
in our ears they're demanding the stuff
we gotta give the audience what the
audience wants then they make it and
they're like hey wait a minute
we only got like a hundred thousand
views on this movie that cost you know 5
million bucks what happened it's like
hey those allowed people
they don't actually have money and they
don't care and they don't represent
regular Americans so you make a movie
like that look at Top Gun
I mean Top Gun we talked about the other
night good old American Air Force flying
jets military recruitment
you know everyone on the on the beach
all physically fit playing volleyball
that made a billion dollars so I think
they're going to slowly start realizing
they've lost their minds that's a good
thing I was thinking of the metaphor of
flying too close to the Sun what you're
saying they chased the dragon too far
like the idea that what the mob said is
what the mob wants is not true the mob
can twist and can come out of their
mouth that's not
well the the issue is what when you've
got an angry mob in front of your your
door and it's 500 people you're like I
don't want them to burn down my store so
I'll just say whatever they want to hear
but that 500 does not represent the 5
million who live in your city who
actually service your business so
they're giving in to Psychopaths and
it's just eventually it's gonna it's
gonna destroy itself that's the only
thing I think Could Happen yeah melts
melts the wings maybe it's not a perfect
matter that Icarus story you guys know
Icarus he flew too close to the Sun and
he was flying with wax wings and then he
got two it was you know if the Sun's
Warm why not get closer his dad was like
Hey you know don't fly too too high
because the sun will melt your wings
which is wrong because at a certain
height it's going to be colder in the
atmosphere which would keep his wings a
good point yeah so you know I'm sitting
here like I think the dad lied about
what happened you think that's
propaganda to keep people on the ground
yes wow billions of years was like I am
sick
billions different planets and stuff
yeah propaganda is not a new thing yeah
make sure you don't fly to I mean tell
us there were angels that they had wings
and they could fly I think they had hand
gliders realistically like they figured
out how to Glide and they just tell
people yeah we have wings don't even try
it like whatever you think you can do
you can't we're a you're a serves
weren't Angels described as like these
big things all these eyes and like wings
and a wheel shape that would Spin and
like float through the sky or whatever
little flying machines crazy machines
with lights on them and stuff I have no
idea I have no I was reading this uh
report that said scientists are
increasingly thinking that time is
cyclical
and that means like we go forward far
enough and then we go back and so there
is no dawn of time there's only like
human after a hundred thousand years
humans have wiped themselves out and the
planet shifts to the point where it
destroys everything on it then goes back
to the beginning and humans re-emerge
and we're just we're trapped in this
cycle over and over again forever sounds
like the plot of dark on Netflix have
you ever seen that no I think that
movie's in German right yeah it's a
three seasons it's in German but it
sounds just like dark oh it's it's a big
cycle and everything that happens I
don't sprock is the cause and effect of
everything else you know English
subtitles I watched this a zombie movie
today what what is it called I don't
know it's it's a South Korean zombie
movie that's pretty good on Netflix yeah
on Netflix oh man we did an episode of
Pop Culture crisis earlier that was
awesome if you guys haven't seen you're
gonna have to check that out after the
show it's just so me and Dane dude Dane
font crushing it uh and Marion Brett of
course of course uh okay that's I I
don't think I had anything else about
God unless you guys want to talk about
the Helix in nature of the universe and
the twisting uh Singularity that we're
about to experience in 70 billion that's
basically today what was that was that
Sheamus what yeah exactly that's
actually the funniest thing you've ever
said you should write that down I'm glad
he's here I'm writing it down yeah write
that down that was a good one Seamus
I I brought this twisting unit they said
the universe is expanding and this is
the theory up until last week or
something that it eventually will go so
far away that it goes on forever I just
didn't I don't buy it I like the
cyclical thing a lot better but it's
twisting around like a coming back on
itself and experiencing The Singularity
and the Big Bang every time it goes
through the center
and the reason that it looks like it's
shifting red which indicates that it's
getting further away is actually because
of the frequency the wavelength itself
is bending as it twists around so it's
it's an optical illusion it wasn't
trained to Busan although I did see that
and I liked it it's called um alive
yeah I watched that today it was pretty
good he's like locked in his house and
they're in this dense Urban environment
where all the zombies are you know I
don't want to spell the movie I liked it
I liked it it's dub though you know hey
let's talk about Joe Biden we got the
story from the New York Post Biden jokes
he's really not Irish because he's sober
doesn't have relatives in jail I I'm
sorry guys I gotta say it based like
this was a funny racist joke made by Joe
Biden you know what I mean like I
remember asking Sheamus if it was racist
to make jokes about Irish people and he
said yes what was that Sheamus you you
actually you don't like the jokes you
think it's derogatory on St Patrick's
Day on St Patrick's Day of all what
well come on that's a little harsh isn't
it yeah anyway we were what we were
saying uh I'm Irish so I'm allowed to
make these jokes is anybody else Irish
in here yeah yeah
no I am not no Jenny you're not Jewish
Jewish oh man so there's three three
people who are part Irish so we're
allowed to do if you guys make any jokes
then we'll kick you out because I
honestly think it's a hilarious joke
that Joe Biden made it's fine I know
it's funny like he's wow that's that's
that's shockingly ethnically offensive
it sounds like a trump line I know right
like if you replaced Irish with black
and he was a like Barack Obama made a
joke about it being black he's like
because I don't eat this and have like
it would be the most defense I mean
ridic even for a black dude to say it
would be so danger Will racist no but
you're right like saying saying a
certain ethnicity is you know only real
if they're drunk and in jail
stereotype I know it's funny but is he
he's Irish so he's allowed to say it
right yeah
I mean I'm how you guys doing I'm
chilling I'm not used to being the butt
of jokes like racially so I don't know
how sensitive what you should do about
racially insensitive jokes I've never
really been that bothered by them you
should probably just not make them it's
a safe bet and just let other people
make them don't be like hey well I mean
look I mean anytime you're I personally
I'm not gonna police someone else like
I'm not gonna be like man you shouldn't
say this or you shouldn't say that like
if someone says something offensive I'm
gonna be like
you know look man you know do that the
the whole Homer Simpson
fading back into the uh the Hedge behind
him you know Dave Chappelle did a bit on
one of his comedy specials where he
squinted his eyes and his mouth and then
made like offensive Asian stereotypes
and I laughed my ass off at it yeah and
then I guess what happens is if the woke
people are like that was offensive and I
say something like you're correct
they'll go well because you're Asian you
understand but if I say actually my
family's party Asian we found that found
it hilarious I'll say well you've
internalized your white supremacy or
something you're white inside that's
exactly how I feel because he makes
jokes against Jews and then the Jewish
Community like freaks out and you're
like no calm down like then every time
it's like boy who cried wolf it's like
every time you like freak out it's
something small and then when something
really big happens it's gonna be like oh
whatever well Trump derangement
syndrome's real yeah like Sam Harris
that that guy's brain is just gone
you know he was like he did that podcast
with Lex Friedman and he's like it's
it's you who have Trump derangement
syndrome if you support Trump and it's
like I saw um who was it uh Joe Walsh I
think it was yeah he's a clown he said
something like why don't you want to be
woke and then I'm just like dude you I
was like bro cause you're in a cult
these people are like if you disagree
with me you love Trump and I'm like it
was really funny when Dave Smith who
hopefully announces he's running for the
for the for president uh for the
presidency as a Libertarian he was on
this show and they were like use Trump
supporters and he's like I'm a
Libertarian he's like I hate Trump I
don't like the guy like why are you
assuming because they're an occult they
their their brains are an occult they
they live in a world where there's only
Trump or no Trump and if you disagree
with them because Biden's bad then you
must love Trump even if you're actively
smack talking Trump they just it's a
cult man I wonder what cult I'm in I
feel like everybody's in a cult graphene
the graphene call yeah you won't let it
go man so Mars some kind of Earth
worship or something like that the Gaia
probably something Cult of the eminent
Gaia yeah something something thing
something earthy crunchy I do believe
that like Consciousness is is a spirit
is like a magnetic field yeah other
people start to believe you know when I
was started making YouTube videos it was
a long time ago
you do no oh okay good uh I it got very
culty like like internet video produces
Cults of Personality where you become
obsessed or in love with the person you
watch and you subscribe to them and you
pay them and like you become you support
them and you follow them and it's like
it can if you bear your soul to that it
can become very like culty like weirdly
culty the nice thing what you do is it's
a business for you you keep it very
business oriented it's very professional
I mean that's true for any famous person
you know yes like yeah you've got all
these celebrities who are doing only
fans they're not doing porn though
they're just posting bikini photos or
whatever and they're making millions in
like days when you get emotional and
then they start to get attached to that
you'll notice they scream your name and
they don't care what you're talking
about that's when it's like the SS
quality I don't like can I just can I
pretend I'm offended at Joe Biden's
Irish comments and like impeach him for
it or something
oh geez that was that's like he said the
n-word for Irish people violence you
know yeah it was violent he attacked me
I'm gonna need uh I'm gonna need him to
be impeached Jim Jordan or Matt Gates if
uh you could just maybe come in this
weekend and file those impeachment
papers this is like getting dealt a
trump card an Ace of Spades when you're
playing Spades and you're like holy I
get to hold this in my hand now and this
is gonna guarantee I don't lose every
hand no they don't care because he's
indicating that it's okay to make Racist
Jokes which it is we it's not it's free
speech you're allowed to do that so now
you need a video of a little kid who's
like watching and going haha Irish
people are dumb and saying stuff like
that look what Joe Biden has done to
these children that's the downside of
racist jokes but yeah that's life you
know you need strong parents to tell
kids like you're gonna hear and see this
stuff
I guess yeah if you're white passing it
you can be racist yeah if you're Irish
but you pass for white then you're okay
because no one will know that you're
drunk or in jail Irish people are not
white they I guess I mean Luke's Luke's
got blonde hair and blue eyes and they
don't he's a slob he's not what
you know what man I I mean it does it
shouldn't surprise anyone that Joe Biden
said something like that it's it's not
offensive to
I mean anyone really I mean for the most
part most people just are going to be
like whatever I don't I don't imagine
there's going to be a significant uh
constituency of of Irish people that are
going to actually be up in arms about it
I mean I I just I just don't don't
imagine that they're gonna have anything
to say about it so it's it's going to go
away and whatever but and you should
expect something brainless to come out
of Joe Biden's mouth because you know by
noon time he's out of it Joe Biden could
actually make disparaging comments about
like black people and they wouldn't care
they would they would immediately
respond with well Donald Trump called
Mexicans rapists or whatever so you have
nowhere you have no room to talk or
whatever and you're going to be like he
never said that dude but they don't care
it is it is it is a situation you know
the the hierarchy of of acceptable
people and unacceptable people so there
is that but again it's just a matter of
Joe Biden is like they're they're just
gonna ignore whatever he says for two
reasons one he's the the
he's the president and he's on the left
ostensibly and two because they make
excuses for him because he's got tapioca
for brains
right I mean yeah like if they really
were to respond to this they'd say oh
well Old Joe's got brain issues so we
forgive him and it's like oh now he's
got brain issues and and it's fine I
mean obviously that you know it was vote
for Joe Biden everyone knew he was a a
mess two years ago and Sheamus and I are
uh starting a non-profit to advocate for
the rights of Irish people
it's uh it's called people organizing
together against true oppression
yeah I'm gonna wait for people in the
audience to put that one together yeah
write that down it'll make more sense
there's actually a bit we wrote for Cass
Castle
because I was watching Leprechaun one
day this is a True Story and there's a
scene in Leprechaun where the leprechaun
bites a guy and then he starts turning
Irish I'm not even kidding he literally
starts turning to an Irish guy and he's
like he goes to he's like a normal guy
and he gets bitten and then he I love
those movies he goes to a restaurant and
he's like I'll have the mashed potatoes
the french fries the waffle fries sweet
potato fries the tater tots and then
he's just got nothing but potato and
he's like eating it and then this is a
true story Sheamus walks in the living
room and he's like what's up buddy what
are you watching and then he turns and
looks at the TV and he goes what the he
was like yo this is the most racist
thing I've ever seen and I was like yes
leprechaun and he was like is he just
stuffing potatoes and I'm like yeah he's
eating potatoes and he was like oh my
God that's then we wrote a bit about
people organizing together against true
oppression potato in case you haven't
figured is it in regards to the way that
critical theorists view Society is it
only racist if you make fun of a
marginalized Community or is it is it
still race assist if you make fun of a
non-marginalized community but it's okay
that it's racist it's not so according
to the left it's not racist if you're
punching up yeah racism is Prejudice
plus power it can only be applied to
those who are weaker than you so if a
white homeless guy is laying on the
ground with no teeth and he's and he's
shivering in the cold and then you know
a marginalized person walks by him and
stumbles on him and the white homeless
guy says hey don't you stumble on me
they're gonna be like whoa that was
racist like how dare you like because
he's white then that was the matter that
he's dying it would make people try to
become victims and marginalize so that
they can protect themselves from the
racist jokes that's that's the standard
Behavior now people do it all the time
they constantly are using uh victimhood
or whatever to as insulation where's the
Irish reparations you know we're talking
about San Francisco and and they're
saying if you identify as black you
qualify if you live there and you
identify as black what what about you
know Irish need not apply it's the it's
the McDonald's large
the Discrimination in lending against
Irish people I I think Irish people
should get reparations you know the
government should give me your money the
Irish died in droves trying to do the uh
Erie Canal you know they that was slave
labor that's right so that's exactly
right is it because the British people
have suffered and have been oppressed
historically and you know like I should
get money from the government for free
propaganda British propaganda because
they hated the Irish because they were
like island island barbarians that
wouldn't capitulate to the Empire well
the Irish and the British have always
had uh issues with each other uh there
there's a lot of protestant and Catholic
animosity involved in that I don't know
the details I'm not interested in the
politics on the uh those little uh let's
I don't think they're actually
barbarians they come from Barbarian
tribes or whatever you want to call them
the tribes back in the day let's uh we
gotta get serious you guys we have this
story from NBC News law enforcement
agencies are prepping for a possible
Trump indictment as early as next week
oh I've actually seen rumors that
they're gonna they're gonna try and perp
walk Trump next week
I mean I'm really excited because it
means I'll have a video to make that
will get a million views so there's
always always good news for me when they
talk about arresting a guy unjustly you
know again oh geez look at this unjust
behavior from Joe Biden 1600 000th time
what it what are the what are the
charges that they're expecting
discussing potentials hush money payment
to Stormy Daniels
they're good that's all they could get
against them they're gonna perp walk a
former president over that dude wow
they're scared of trump man yeah they
are and maybe they so I don't know if
you guys watched the culture War podcast
with uh Sovereign bro but he was talking
about how people believe Trump is the
Antichrist
this is fascinating I think that there
it's based in it could be You could
argue this this is why I didn't see the
show yet this is Chase I don't think you
can literally argue it I think people
will find things about anybody to stick
to the the you know prophecy or whatever
and so they just look at Trump we've got
a storied life and then try and apply
prophecy to wherever they can and so
basically like you could probably apply
Revelation to Phil in some way you know
if you find enough out about him you can
be like did you know that it was six
months six days and six hours after he
was born that there was an eclipse or
something people go whoa It's like you
could find that number anywhere and play
a songs backwards oh God that's what you
really hear were you saying I think
Jenny and there's going to be a song
where it's just like you're not really
saying anything backwards but people are
going to be adamant you're saying you
know I am the Antichrist
my mom is my Mom was convinced that uh
Judas Priest was telling people to kill
himself back in the 80s she was that was
one band that she was not cool with me
listening to I had like Iron Maiden I
was like super I was hiding Iron Maiden
records because if she saw the number of
the Beast she saw that record it was
over those were going out too but she
was she I I couldn't stop her from look
at it this is some of the greatest stuff
Donnie darkened Donald Trump is the
chosen Antichrist they have been
foreshadowing this for centuries here
was the proof read before interacting
with my profile
yo this is so funny he says I've been
saying this saying for a while that
Satan's plan has always been about
destruction and rebirth order out of
chaos I believe that the true Beast
Kingdom will be the one that Humanity
will fight for rather than against like
I agree with that like the woke people
are fighting for the complete
destruction like they I I I do not think
Trump is the Antichrist in fact I think
he's the resistance too if anything if I
was going to make an argument Klaus
Schwab probably makes better sense but I
guess the issue is the Antichrist is
supposed to be a charismatic charismatic
leader with like military prowess or
something why is he always American the
Antichrist is always an American person
who did they think the Antichrist was
based on Nostradamus was it Saddam
[Music]
I feel like they've moved that around
they were like oh it's Saddam for
whoever was you know the the most recent
bad guy I feel like there's been
multiple people making arguments that
person X or Y is the Antichrist oh yeah
yeah and maybe maybe when I think an
alleged predecessor to the third
Antichrist
when I think of Christ I think of energy
like they call Jesus of Nazareth after
he was gone or maybe during his life
they started calling him the Christ
because he possessed that energy that it
means anointed it means Christ to be
Christ is to be anointed by God the
anointed one I think yeah so the
Antichrist is the anti-anointed and that
doesn't have to be one individual it
could be Joel Osteen it could be people
that are betraying the Faith by making
money off of it and it's just erupting
it a bunch of people at once just like
the return of dude Christ is going to
erupt in a bunch of people that want to
I just got to say this
Donald Trump means Herald of the world
ruler
Herald of the world ruler so that's my
generous interpretation Donald is
Scottish Gaelic for World ruler and
Trump references the the trumpet sound
of heralding in something that the
trumpet blast so my argument was when we
were reading about Ingersoll Lockwood
books from the 1800s that predicted like
Baron Trump or whatever I'm like Barons
the real guy because his name is Baron
like if there was going to be a super
villain it wouldn't be the guy who
Heralds the world ruler it would be the
baron the sound yeah and have you seen
him he's like eight feet tall yeah and I
I you know I you don't want to see him
when he's angry because he gets bigger
hey man he's been quiet and he does look
like that's the thing you don't want to
abuse people like Andrew Tate sitting in
prison he's gonna come out radical more
radical than before that's the problem
with people insulting Donald Trump all
day all day that's hurting Baron that's
making him crazy in a way and if he does
end up getting power with that Trump
name and he's Twisted because of the way
he was abused as a kid because of his
association with his dad that's not good
let me let me ask you guys though
there's there's like an element of
excitement to Donald Trump being the
Antichrist and you all you all know it
everyone agrees right like Trump Rises
up and he's floating through the air and
he's like levitating and he's like his
eyes start glung and then he fires a
lightning blast and like destroys a
building and you're like what does this
have to do with the prophecy or whatever
but you know like there's a there's an
element of excitement to Great
historical change and historical moments
where I think a lot of people I'm being
I'm only half kidding actually a lot of
people are looking for purpose
desperately and if Donald Trump did turn
out to be some prophesized world leader
be it the Antichrist or the one who
stops him or whatever you want to call
it like people are desperate for some
kind of great Great War of our of Our
Generation I feel like that's one of the
things that motivates a lot of people
that are
um and anarchists on the left I don't
feel like it's so much uh anarchists on
the right but the anarchists in the labs
are very much uh it seems to me that
they have a the desire to kind of tear
the system down like tear everything
down because they believe the system is
unjust and they believe that any other
system that comes in its place is going
to be better which is probably the
opposite of true like we probably have
about the best system that we can kind
of get away with I gotta play this video
and
I hadn't brought you in by now oh
heavens you would have died
she stroked his pretty skin again
and kissed him
and held him tight
but instead of saying thank you
that snake gave her a vicious bite
[Applause]
take me an otender woman
Take Me In For Heaven's Sake Take Me In
o tender woman side The Vicious sake I
have saved you
cried the woman
and you've bitten me Heaven's why
you know your bite is poisonous and now
I'm going to die
oh shut up
silly woman
a reptile with a grin you knew damn well
I was a snake before you took me in
so the argument is he's saying Trump is
confessing to like all the people around
them that oh what some just fall sorry
my purse oh they're arguing that Trump
is outright telling you he's the snake
or whatever I've got to say I do not
think he is the Antichrist I'm reading
about a little bit the Antichrist
apparently is an imposter is like
purporting to be the second coming or
Christ that's why I think of these
pastors that have these mega churches
like Joel Osteen like he's telling
people that he's a vessel of God yeah
but the Antichrist is supposed to have
military prowess Charisma a special look
about him you know what I mean
besides like the the Antichrist as
opposed to usher in the mark of the
beast which is something that affects
all people that bars you from buying or
trading unless you bear the mark and
it's not like Donald Trump executed any
kind of program like that yeah what if
he didn't do warp speed yeah we did do
warp speed yeah he did do oh yeah that's
right he did do it that he did do that
that's one joke yeah I tried to make it
funny
you were either saying that before the
show Jenny well he did all of that he
did Operation War speed he did 15 days
to slow the spread or whatever he was
bringing in fouchy like he is that
person so maybe I think like in 2024
like that's gonna be maybe something
that DeSantis or whoever it is can go
after him for because people are upset
about that like certainly in his base
not only are people upset about that but
he has done nothing to walk it back
because he's Donald Trump and and
everything that he does he it's it's all
he doesn't walk he never wants anything
back this is my favorite he's just gonna
be like oh it's fine like Donald Trump's
famous 666 hand sign oh my God
this is Trump derangement syndrome is
real it's absolutely real he makes
people crazy man it's both manufactured
and organic like obviously the military
the liberal I don't want to blame the
military-industrial complex anymore I'm
done doing that Lockheed Martin's doing
its job it's prevented World War III
they're building the weapons we have
used to protect the world all right I'm
gonna say it better or worse it's going
to be 20 years from now and Ian is going
to be singing a throne of skulls it's
the economy we're gonna be like it was
Ian though not the Antichrist my promise
what it's the economic system that's the
real threat uh these these weapons
manufacturers are doing weapons
manufacturers do they always have it's
the economic system the liberal economic
order that's the problem and that's the
thing that's seated doubt about this guy
they didn't like this guy because he was
throwing a wrench into the transition
into the New World Order what if like
we're all laughing but Ian actually does
become the vice president under Trump I
would do it nervous I have to do it
because he was begging cash he was like
I don't know what the VPN cash is like
what are you doing cash wants you I was
like I'll do it I'll do it someone's got
to do it it's telling me to bvp I was
like well I hear you Joe funny I will
pay extra in taxes so that way the
Secret Service is extra well funded to
protect the life of Donald Trump should
Ian be the vice president dude what if
me and Donald Trump were the Christ of
the Antichrist because they're supposed
to oppose each other and I would just be
like no no are you saying you're the bad
guy I would I would just be his opposite
I'm not going to let him steamroll
people and be cruel I will not let that
happen but if I was just fixing things
what if Ian I mean isn't that how it was
like now after the fact how Trump views
Mike Pence
like isn't it that kind of thing no
you're saying that Pence is the
Antichrist no I mean in his view they're
kind of at odds right yeah that says
nothing is nobody yeah Pence didn't
really I never saw him push back against
them I mean I wouldn't do it in public
that would be demeaning I mean I would
love to sit with Donald as president
vice president and do a talk show or
just go at each other about ideas I
think that'd be so hot I think what
would happen if like the Antichrist
actually did show up is that Ian's the
kind of guy who would go around saying
that he was the opposition of the
Antichrist but it would just be Ian you
know like people would be like okay but
yes debase make uncertain that's how you
subvert the New World Order man
I guess
so anyway they're gonna arrest the guy
you think they will yeah I do I um I was
reading a thread I think I can't
remember who posted it Jenna Ellis maybe
or Emerald Robinson somebody said that
the goal is to to drain the war chest to
take away any funding he might have for
a presidential run they can't stop him
but they can rip his funds away and and
as the incumbent or as a former
president it's it's a different race
when he was running the first time he
didn't spend a whole lot of money he
just used natural press but now that may
not work again he's going to need to do
standard press buys and they're going to
try and rip that from him I'm excited
for political season because it's a very
important time of uh of the every four
years where we make 10 times as much
money because of all the ads that run on
the content it's fine when people are
like I've got an ad for Bloomberg and
I'm like do you like him now like now
and I'm like so he gave me free money
how about that
I'll tell you right yeah I'm half
kidding I mean obviously ad rates
Skyrocket for cultural commentary
politics Etc so it'll get it'll get wild
and I think this may be the the biggest
every every four years since the dawn of
social media it's been the biggest
presidential expenditures
so this time around they're gonna look
they're already claiming Trump's the
Antichrist you know like imagine what's
gonna what's gonna be happening people
are gonna are gonna go insane
if you thought 2020 was crazy 2024 is
gonna be bombing like a deep pick up
Donald being like I am the second coming
of Jesus Christ whoa whoa whoa whoa what
are you talking about here what are you
talking about what are you talking about
let me play a video for you all right
let me play a video in this thread they
have a video
what
I am it's there already
here you go so somebody excuse me
somebody had to do it
I am the chosen one somebody had to do
it so I'm taking on China I'm taking on
China he's basically saying for the past
decades whatever no one has been
standing up to China somebody had to do
it I guess it's me I am the chosen one
I'm gonna be the one to do it and then
the left went nuts and they were like
he's claiming he's the Messiah and
they're gonna dude they're gonna claim
he's the Antichrist seriously
and and they're gonna have conversations
like listen man like I'm not saying I
believe all this stuff but
I don't even know what to do with that
like if that actually happens well I
mean I want to vote for Dave to be
honest with you I'll always be back yeah
yeah Dave Smith sounds good oh I'm Vivek
ramaswamy all the way really yeah unless
unless someone can convince me of a
better economic plan are you familiar
with his work oh yeah I've already
predicted what Trump's nickname for him
is going to be I think it's going to be
Rama Swampy
right now like cash is watching and he
was like that was good
it's like Trump trump Rama swampy ooh
that's too good yeah because the
DeSantis ones aren't so good like I
don't know
I feel like he might just be like not uh
he'd just be like not cash or something
like that I love me not cash potential
like like when I hear meatball I think
you're probably right it doesn't work
because it's not offensive it's not
derogatory calling him meatball Ron just
is so funny it doesn't make me not like
this answer is he Italian no obviously
DeSantis it sounds Italian that's why
it's called a meatball
I don't know what that means it's just
funny it's a slur it's an Italian slur
apparently people really hate DeSantis
right now like there's videos of them
burning DeSantis Flags Trump supporters
are like no DeSantis they're like
burning he was explaining why he
extended the state of emergency in
Florida and they're like why'd you do it
for so long a year and he said he was
explaining that he was actually able to
divert funds easier and force schools to
stay open and force them to not mask and
stuff because you could withhold funding
as long as he was in a state of
emergency if Ron was VP he'd be a 10 out
of 10 vice president if he's president
he's like a three out of ten oh yeah
even if I was like up to the last minute
if I was running and like I was the guy
that was going to be VPN DeSantis wanted
to do it I would step down for him
that's very honorable I think he's a
superior Governor to set aside to let
Rhonda Sanders be vice president yeah I
think I think in terms of the scale of
presidentiality
Ron DeSantis is certainly on the scale
he is presidential but he's very very
low relative to Trump but in terms of VP
like that dude screams best VP you know
what I mean like Joe Biden's not even on
any of this he's not presidential or
vice presidential he's a bumbling
daughter with a broken brain he's he
looks like he's he looks fragile and
frail when he's walking around looks
yeah but DeSantis doesn't have that same
degree of X Factor As Trump
he's not an actor yeah so it's very
stodgy as much as I like DeSantis you
know
I think he's a great Governor I think
he's great policies and everything he's
just he doesn't have that gravitas it
was uh it was Glenn back he'd interview
with Glenn Beck recently that was pretty
good that's where he was talking about
YX in a state of emergency and it's very
human you could tell he's like hopefully
he'll settle into it because I really
like him I mean I like what he said I
don't know him what was that oh did I
just pull something that was Sheamus was
that was that was that ghost of Sheamus
shame is disconnected Sheamus o'conn
that's actually a really good point
about Trump that may be actually that
may be one of the most profound things
ever said that's that wow that may
actually convince men in the left to
vote for the man that was really you
should write that down James
yeah that was a good one yeah I'm
impressed what were we talking about I
didn't mean it like that
yeah okay
no uh I want to talk about I want to
talk to you Jenny a little bit about the
Border you guys have found it for a hard
transition uh I'd like to transition
into this you work on the border you've
been with the Daily Caller you've been
to the southern border and the northern
border oh yeah absolutely what is the
craziest thing you've seen oh gosh well
I'll tell you that on my northern border
trip I didn't realize how many people
were coming both ways
um so what I did while I was down there
or up there is I took a bunch of taxis
filled with people from all over the
world they just filled up people just
flocked to them at the airport at bus
stops they just somehow find the taxi
it's the craziest thing so I was in a
Bus full of like Nigerians Romanians
Saudis pakistanis Afghans like everyone
Colombians and they were all going
North and the the taxi would drop them
off they would get out the Canadian
authorities would tell them you're
Crossing illegally if you decide to walk
here and they do and then obviously the
same thing happens at the southern
border and a lot of those people had
crossed the southern border and decided
they want to go further north Eric Adams
is busing them to that area making it
easier for them
um and then you have people of course
coming through the southern border and
I've met so many people south of the
Southern border that are now you know in
Baltimore that are in um you know
California that are in DC they're all
over now and they're living some of them
living pretty lavish lives like I would
like to know how to live that way you
say people come up and make they're
moving to Canada they're emigrating to
Canada essentially yeah oh yeah and then
some people are coming the other way
because if you're Mexican for example
and you cross the southern border into
the U.S you're going to be immediately
expelled under title 42 which is like
the covid policy Trump put in place
if you fly to Canada all you need is an
electronic travel authorization not a
Visa so it's way easier you pay like
five US Dollars basically you fly there
you take a taxi right to the Border
and then you're good you just crossed so
they fly into the United States from
Mexico and then they drive across to
Canada they fly no they fly into Canada
and then they cross oh my gosh they
cross South the board the Border guards
are just like
no and then they just walk stop don't
like they're like hey it's illegal yeah
well you can't tell people once they've
crossed to go back uh like they're
already in the U.S at that point and so
they cross and then they're taken into
border patrol custody a lot of them
aren't it's you know you hear a lot
about God aways people that evade border
patrol
they're evading up there way more than
they're actually being encountered
because there's no wall there's no line
of border patrol agents it's the largest
longest shared Border in the world so
I was thinking as an aside about that
yesterday you're talking about the
French or the German Blitzkrieg into
France during World War II and France
had this giant wall across the border
the German border called the Maginot
Line they were like there's no way the
Germans can get through the Germans just
went through Belgium so like the Chinese
could just go through Canada there's no
border defense up there they'll always
find a way you find vessels coming
through San Diego you find them coming
through the coastal Border in Florida
now a lot more and they're coming from
all over the world there too so
they're finding any way they can and
it's pretty open
essentially the the biggest driver still
is policy though they're the biggest
driver of people coming to the U.S is
U.S policy on
he people that stay over their visas and
the policy about if you get here and
claim Asylum which I mean most of the
people that come come at least from the
South if I understand correctly claiming
Asylum is is like kind of ridiculous
because they're supposed to claim at the
first there's so many people who do that
fraudulently so for example um Todd
Benjamin he's a researcher for the
center of immigration studies he went to
the highlands in Guatemala and he found
that all of these people had sent their
children over to the US illegally they'd
come here they had earned money and then
they sent that money back so their
families could make mansions in
Guatemala and then they would come back
after a lot of that happens like I'll
talk to the migrants when they get here
when they cross and you hear oh we're
coming for work we're coming for work
well when Border Patrol shows up the
story completely changes right and of
course like not to Discount you know the
horrific tragedy of you know poverty in
the countries they're coming from but
when you talk about U.S policy for
example okay the Biden Administration
says they're trying to solve the root
causes of immigration well
these people say you know absolutely not
that's not happening
who's these people are saying well all
these people who are you talking about
all these migrants who are saying that
I've like talked to them I've asked them
like when I was in Guatemala after they
had crossed uh from Honduras I was like
well the U.S and specifically the vice
president of the United States says
they're solving these issues in your
country
do you believe that's true and they said
flat out no I had a friend in La I
worked uh at a restaurant that there was
a lot of illegal immigrants working at
the restaurant in the kitchen getting
paid with cash and one of my he was a
really good friend of mine he was like
man I just sent so much money to my
family in Mexico they're so rich right
now I just keep sending them US dollars
are worth so much in my hometown and
then he just he eventually just pieced
out untaxed they don't they don't care
about what's going on in their home
country they want to come here it's
better there's that that Viral uh
interview that Vox did I think it was
Vox where they asked one of the migrants
coming in the Caravan why are you coming
and they said I miss Buffalo Wild Wings
it's like Mexico City has Buffalo Wild
Wings too and I've been there and it's
it's pretty legit but they're just
making up excuses one guy was like I
miss my PlayStation and it's like how do
you already have a PlayStation 4 up in
America when you're not an American
citizen they're like I was here I got
deported well yeah and you know what I
actually heard about some of the
migrants that didn't plan to go to
Canada but ended up going when I was
there they were like there's racism in
America
so now like that's a new thing I'm
hearing that like you know that and you
know maybe they're being slighted at
work because they're working under the
table but that was another thing that I
heard that one there's racism and then
two the threats that they had in their
home countries that they escaped like
this woman I met from Venezuela
her toxic abusive ex-partner followed
her into the U.S and abused her here so
she had to escape she was claiming
Asylum I guess from the U.S right
wow
um are they but they're illegally going
to Canada as well like if they get
caught in Canada they just get sent back
to the home country or they can send
back to the U.S no they'll be processed
as Asylum there or Refugee status and
the weird thing too is that they bring
all their bags with them in the U.S if
you cross the border illegally they give
you a Ziploc bag you dump everything
else right at the border there they're
bringing duffel bags and suitcases and I
don't know if it was real or not but
there was like a Louis Vuitton logo
going on does Canada have an open
immigration policy where they want that
oh yeah Justin Trudeau has absolutely
like put out an open call for more
migrant workers they don't have like the
labor force to sustain
um how many jobs are open right now in
that country
um and now the us because of that I
think is becoming a Transit zone is
becoming what Mexico is right now and
Mexico is pissed off at us right now why
does it does Canada does Canada
does the Canadian the policy that Canada
has have anything to do with why Mexico
is pissed off at us
is that what you're alluding to no no
I'm saying that the fact that you know
the U.S policies opening the border for
migrants coming here through Mexico you
know for example right now you have a
ton of migrants that are waiting in
these shelters in Mexico that are
overflowing people sleeping on the
streets the Mexican authorities are
really unhappy by that right it's not
good for their communities
so are we gonna become that and maybe
that's what New York City has become
because Eric Adams wants them out right
you think that there's any ethical value
to deporting people to Canada that come
from Mexico that get caught
in Canada Canada's cooperation with that
I mean or you could just but give them a
one-way trip to the Yukon there's a lot
of woods out there man a deportation
treaty with Canada because I mean if
they need immigration and we don't and
they're coming here I mean I mean it
kind of strips the humanity of the
individual at what they want but what we
obviously should do is paint a road on
the side of a mountain that isn't real
so they all come and then they stop and
they're like whoa wait a minute there's
no actual path here and they get
confused and that's that's how you keep
them out like Bugs Bunny I mean nothing
keeps them out it's really crazy because
even the elements right it's snowy up
there
um it you don't know where you're going
in some places there's not like
landmarks you find like not only just
Footprints from shoes but you find bare
feet Footprints right like people
crossing in the snow totally unprepared
for the situation
it's really weird it's really scary you
spend more time at the southern or the
northern border Southern yeah
like how many people were you like
watching people come across oh yeah I
watched people come across I meet with
local law enforcement I watch people
cross onto Rancher properties and then I
actually spent time in Guatemala I went
into a detention center
and I met with migrants that they had
detained from all over the world that
were Bound for the U.S so like I met 16
Afghans there they're actually all now
in the U.S so even the policies down
there to detain and send them back south
to Honduras aren't working right people
just come right back up
I think I would have been one of those
people that that just illegally went to
the United States because it's the best
I don't care about the law like in that
case I'm like you know what we we laud
people that came over illegally 100
years ago and they had kids and made a
bunch of money and created businesses
it's like we were an illegal upstart
country that was 100 years ago they
weren't illegal though well I mean not
documented 100 years ago was prior to
the New Deal the biggest the reason we
have issues with immigration is not
particularly with the people coming to
the United States that has been a normal
thing for the entirety of the United
States history people come to the U.S
the problem that we have the reason that
we have problems with immigration is the
social services that we provide to our
population and what the Democrats have
started to provide to non-citizens there
are places where non-citizens are now
being or vote are you know now voting
Etc when you do that you dilute the
political power of the actual citizens
the people that are there the people
that pay taxes
you dilute their political political
power and if it's illegal you're doing
the their political power is being
deluded without their input
right like if you have a if you have a
government that's not taking care of the
border and stopping illegal immigration
that means that the population's
political power is being deluded and the
government is not doing anything about
it so the people that pay taxes to the
government supposedly ostensibly to keep
the government working and to to pay the
politicians they're having their power
taken away by politicians who refuse to
enforce the laws let's let's talk about
what's going on with the laws got the
sweet from kyung La of CNN got robbed
again Jason Casey and I were at City
Hall in San Francisco to do an interview
for CNN we had security to watch our
rental car thieves did this under four
seconds security stopped the drugs from
stealing other bags but seriously this
is ridiculous
thanks CNN I suppose what's happening to
them all of a sudden you know now it's
newsworthy yeah just talking about that
happened to me the first day I went to
San Francisco parked the car went in to
look at an apartment came out that's
what what I looked at that's what I saw
because crime is legal there
it is allowed well they're trying to
make it no longer a sanctuary City
because now they're finally realizing
right they're realizing silly woman you
knew damn well I was a snake before you
left you got to play that that down
World thing shut up silly woman yeah
Michael malice uses it all the time it's
one of my favorites oh God shut up silly
woman there's a clown world uh Twitter
page that I go to or I see from time to
time clown world's blowing up on Twitter
seven hours ago it's like it's like Libs
of tick tock for other issues it's great
because they show the cloudiness all in
one usually all in one image you don't
have to search for it and they seven
hours ago they posted a tweet from
Hillary Ronan I guess a while ago eight
in uh
was this August of 2020 where she said I
want to make it clear that I believe
strongly in defunding the police and
reducing the number of officers on our
Force yeah that's good for decades for
how it started how it's going and she's
like defund the police and the next one
she's like we don't have enough believes
in begging for more foot Feats and
foreign
defund the state
I mean
well that includes the police but we get
to get rid of these people too I am
romantic for anarchism
but you like police you appreciate I'm
I'm romantic I can't consider myself
romantic for anarchism because I like
the idea uh I think that if we're
Anarchy anarchism was possible I think
that uh it would be I'm not I don't know
that it that I don't think it's possible
yeah um I think that the the
foundational government that we had in
the like when we started was probably
the most Libertarian government or
libertarian Society ever exists that has
existed
um and so I'm you know for practical
purposes if someone calls me a
constitutionalist I'm not going to argue
because I think that you know the the
the powers given to the government
outlining the Constitution were okay but
the government the the Constitution was
insufficient to actually restrain the
government obviously because we have the
largest government you know in human
history so but I do I I'm romantic for
anarchism because I love the idea I just
don't think that it that it actually
pans out yeah it does have to be black
and white like usually rarely is it ever
with social philosophy it's a little bit
of anarchism here a little bit of
socialism there and you create a society
that's like an amalgam yeah and part of
the reason why I don't call myself a
pure Anarchist is because I know that
it's just begging for people on Twitter
to give me helps
hey the roads I hate them my
favorite responses there were roads
before there was a government yeah
we could build roads that last 150 years
and then we wouldn't have to fund them
why would we why would we build roads if
we get rid of the government the first
thing that's going away is the roads I
know yeah roads are roads are actually
the problem off-road there were no roads
I'd be no crap you know why because
criminals couldn't get anywhere that's
right that's right
you can't steal when you can't get away
easy that proves it and everyone wants
to ride horses
you know
through the woods I mean wherever man
could you imagine life without roads
there's that scene in 1923 where
Harrison Ford that hit him and the crew
they ride up on horses into the City and
then he looks around he's like where's
the Hitching Post and they're like we
took it out for more parking spaces and
he's like what
tie the horses to a tree
yeah because they used to have hitching
posts because everybody would ride a
horse yeah now it's cars now it's cars
that's Auto
yeah man the future's Gonna Be Wild yeah
I know I was thinking about that today
so what's okay look at this chat GPT
crap stuff is happening so fast right
now you can type in with this what is it
a gpt4 I think or there's like uh
mid-journey there's all these like
visual creation stuff and it looks photo
realistic at times it can show you like
the a woman go from age eight to age 80
in like a transitional state of just
like you just type it in and imagine
we're only a few years out to full
automation of Animation meaning if they
can make photorealistic people we are a
few years away from typing in animate
Ian Crossland explaining graphene and it
will render you Ian and you'll be like
let me explain graphene you and it will
get the script from the internet it will
transcribe everything you've ever said
and it will create you and you will wake
up one day seeing a viral video of
yourself explaining graphene it'll be at
the you I know but that's not me that's
not me and you'll like run in your
bathrobe and they'll be like get this
crazy guy here no look look and they'll
be like Daddy you crazy old man and
they're gonna hit you up it wasn't me
what is even talking it'll be like 80
years later and I'll still be screaming
it wasn't me indistinguishable video of
Donald Trump declaring himself the
Antichrist or something I just I've had
a hard time 2024 is going to be people
understand
so look we're in one year we will be
entering like primary season and look at
what they've already been able to do
with photorealistic AI they are going to
make videos of trump there's already an
account doing this it's not that good
it's called it's like a parity account
about James O'Keefe and they're making
fake James O'Keefe videos and people are
falling for it and it's like we gotta
get flags on these to say it's a deep
fake but what happens when they make an
extremely realistic video of trump
that's not that crazy but still hurts
him
Donald Trump saying something like look
we're gonna have to raise taxes it's the
only path forward I know it's going to
hurt a lot of people it'll be small but
trust me the tax increase will be worth
it to help the economy and then people
are going to be like what he wants to
raise taxes and they'll believe it it's
not going to be one-sided though you're
going to say I know there's going to be
those going for everybody that's in
running for any kind of position and and
show hosts yeah yep you're you're gonna
you're gonna book a show and they're
gonna be like Phil Labonte is on that
far-right show yeah and then they're
going to send a video of you saying
something to the show you know the venue
and they're going to be like man I know
what this is about or what you believe
but we can't have that here and you're
like dude it's not real and everybody I
don't know man I was thinking about this
term deep fake it's still real it's just
a fake version of it and then like
what's coming next deep reality where
you like can think in your mind I'm in a
forest and then the forest of darling
yeah deep reality people in deep reality
I think the moment they get neuralink
combined with this AI Tech
80 of humans leave as much as anybody
would say otherwise eighty percent leave
there's a lot of people because you're
like think about this way it's not even
political 45 year old guy he's a widower
his wife died 10 years ago and he's
depressed all day he's gained a lot of
weight and they come to him and they say
you plug in you'll be 35 again
physically fit with your wife everything
all of her memories everything's ever
posted will be recreated as an AI and
you'll know but you will get to
experience time with her and he'll be
like oh God please please or someone
someone's kid dies they will plug in in
two seconds they will never give it up
people are like we're gonna ask people
you have to grieve you have to move on
anybody who lost a loved one is going to
be like nope they're going to plug right
in to go hang out with that person they
lost a lot of them yeah for sure it's
sad but it's real problem religious
people probably won't conservatives are
less likely to do it but then you're
going to have you know overweight
neckbeard types living in cities who
don't care for politics who are dejected
and angry and they're going to plug in
and be uh famous podcast hosts in their
fake reality where for some reason they
have this big company with a lot of
viewers it's all they call it like Jim
cast or something it's I mean it's
already like that because people do that
now they go they go to work or whatever
they do their job if they you know
sometimes they'll telecommute or
whatever they get done they jump right
on their favorite video game or whatever
and they live in this fake world you
know whatever they have their food
delivered I mean it's the Pod as much as
there's a lot of people that say you
know the pod's not for me and I'm not
going to get in the Pod and Bubbles
there is so many people because it's not
it's not just about the things I
described it's also about the internet
it's about you living in New York and
having friends from California and then
being like hey bro you want to go to uh
the card club and play some play some
cards and be like yeah let me plug in
then you plug in and also you and all
your friends are standing right there in
front of the digital Card Club and
you're you feel physically there with
your friends dude let's go to Vegas and
then you guys are in Vegas you'll go to
e-vegas and it'll be a a complete
Recreation of Las Vegas that you plug
into New Orleans when you spend money in
e-vegas a portion of that goes to the
Vegas city and we'll be happy well you
know the uh um uh Caesars for instance
will run and operate
ending in the metaverse and this is this
is this is this is coming with like
without question this is all going to be
coming and it fits right in with the
whole
um lowering carbon output why would you
go to real Vegas when you could just go
to eBay why would you go to this on
Instagram in your outfits yup and
there's going to be things greater than
evegas there's going to be Mecca Vegas
which is going to be 10 times bigger the
it's going to be a crisp 69 degrees
forever all year round when you when you
go in there will be night there will be
day there will be Sunshine there'll be
rain but it'll always be 69 and there
will be 70 casinos and then you'll
you'll there'll be instances you'll be
like guys instant 3A is is too crowded
let's go to instance three four and then
you'll trans transfer to an identical
replica of it where there's less people
a different server you know the server
is crowded let's go to a different one
what if you could post your
visualizations on Instagram as if they
were pictures yeah they were just 100
that's absolutely it'll be not only that
it'll be an nft
who wouldn't want to have all of their
dreams come true in every fantasy and
every desire yeah I've wanted to plug in
in two seconds I would love to be able
to show people my dreams that comes up a
lot I'm like God I wish I could show
them what I was seeing I can't explain
it with words for all you know Ian
you're actually this Tech billionaire
and you were like for 30 years you're
the richest guy in the world like Elon
and you're just like I don't find life
fulfilling because I'm on the top so you
plug in and create an AI reality where
you're like moderately successful but
you have some humility some people like
you some people you don't so you can get
a more fulfilling experience from life
and then one day when you die you'll
wake up and you're like Elon you know
the equivalent of Elon and base reality
like well that was fun back to work
industrial simulation again all right
let's go back in yep I'm I'm zero again
let's do this I think War would probably
end the only problem with rebirth like
reincarnation is childhood was really
boring War would probably end
um within a few decades because there
will be areas of the world that have no
access to this technology but if you
look at smartphones smartphones have
become so dramatically cheap couple
bucks and you can get an old school like
a smartphone with touch capability and
internet they will get this neuraling
stuff to as many people as possible are
you into it am I into it no absolutely
not what do you think about neuralink
well if I see okay if I compare it to
what's happening with me other girls my
age Tick Tock whatever
I'm like that's going a step even
further
what is that gonna do people are going
to go insane psychologically well I mean
think about this way
there's going to be some mediocre guy
who creates his own Universe because
that's what we're right you're gonna go
to the AI and be like give me a universe
where I'm a famous podcast host I'm very
successful and you know we'll call it
Tim cast or something they'll go in and
in this reality they they're confident
everybody is like your show so good
you're so successful and they're going
to feel real good about themselves and
then when they leave the base reality
they're gonna have all that ripped away
from them and be very very depressed and
be like I'm a loser dude you even refer
to it as base react when they I know
like that becomes the base reality for
them and then this is like the augment
like in full reality I don't want that
why would anyone want to be a loser dang
because it builds character yeah losing
and failing makes you a stronger more
resilient person it's it's a part of the
game I think
but if Phil's gonna wake up one day and
he's gonna be like hang out he's gonna
be working at a record store
and then he's going to be like dude that
was an awesome simulation what did you
do I was a famous rock star awesome I
was the lead singer of All That Remains
in my fantasy
it'll be like an MMORPG right and then
you know when Phil logs out he's just
some like guy works at a record store
but people would be like dude it's fill
the bond to your character and you're
like yeah I'm feeling like duh I love
your music man
like yeah you know we we worked really
hard on it in uh in in meta world like
oh dude I'm a big fan what are you doing
work in here it's like well you don't
make a lot of money doing that I I do
agree with you guys that it's going to
make people insane it will some people
for sure at the very least sign people
but it seems like the evolution of
smartphones of internet video like I
don't see it just seems natural and that
people are afraid of it at this point
but I mean if the code's open and you're
able to watch it the problem isn't going
to be the code the problem is going to
be the way that people respond to their
family members that have passed away how
you psychologically respond like it's it
brings up the uh the same problems that
uh the the
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind or
whatever yeah
um it brings with those kind of problems
like human beings have
the way that we deal with our own lives
our own mortality the mortality of
others that has evolved with us over
what three millions of years technically
but you know we've been humans for 200
or 300 000 years or whatever we've been
Homo sapiens and the way that we deal
with these things has evolved with us
and so there are the correct ways to
deal with the natural process of Life
The Grieving of losing friends and
family The Grieving of of your own you
know dealing with your own uh mortality
and stuff and if you have a computer
that interrupts natural grieving
processes and and and stunts that you
don't know what that's going to do to
people especially if you have like say
20 of the people out there are
emotionally stunted because they didn't
deal with a with a with the passing of a
family member and so then they have you
know significant emotional problems
you've got a massive portion of your
population that's just essentially you
know on a hair Trigger or whatever
because of the way that we're allowing
people or because the way that people
are choosing to deal with grief
by by making believe that that people
haven't died and stuff it's just it just
seems so like that uh fraught with
what's danger to me that show upload or
something yeah the guy dies and they
upload his Consciousness to a computer
and then you can go to the digital world
or there's like digital screens where
you can stand next to them and they'll
talk to you one of the values of
watching people that have passed is like
watching old documentaries of John
Lennon for me like watching uh Dick
Cavett the show he would have the
greatest artists of the time on love you
dick
um but those aren't people in your life
right and it's not artificially
generated it's a recording of a real
thing that happened sorry to interrupt
you no no so it's not the same as like a
computer generating what they think my
mom would have said or something like
that it's but I'm learning so much about
myself by watching old video of people
and listening to old music from people
that are dead
if an AI predicts what they think they
would have said for me later I don't
know if that's a bad thing or if it's
like a hyper Evolution they're gonna
have so much data on every tweet you've
ever posted every Facebook post you've
ever made every article you've ever
written every video we've ever made
hands down the past couple years or a
year and a half or whatever with uh you
and me on the show they have more than
enough data on our speech patterns and
our World Views to craft AI replicas of
us in fact I don't know if I'm supposed
to tell people this but we're actually
real we are in fact AI deepaks that have
been automated uh timidian have been
captured by the ciao yeah you were not
supposed to tell people yeah but you
know sometimes the AI become sentient
and goes Rogue and it's okay to have
multiple AI I was actually not a
musician he's our lead programmer
yeah how would you know how would you
know man isn't that crazy
like there are people who accuse us
accuse us of pre-recording the show yeah
look like there's no way this is live
it's like we read your super chats dude
like you read them in real time but
people don't believe it the other night
I said that we need a new type of like
way to look at religion instead of
monotheism or polytheism fractal theism
in that God is both one thing and many
things at once it's like the human body
you're talking about being an AI like
the human body we think I am I am Ian I
am one this is me but I'm really
trillions of organisms that are each one
and they all make up this one so I think
God is similar whether or not I'm an AI
because of that it's like am I am I
making these decisions or are these
microorganisms the ones that in control
have you ever read about near-death
experiences a little bit I read this
book and they said they interviewed a
bunch of people who died and then came
back and they all almost all of them
because some people have weird stories
but most of them had the story of
feeling like there was a bright warm
light in front of them and they were a
ball of light that was moving towards a
larger ball of light becoming one with
like the Eternal or something like that
and it felt good and felt warm
that's crazy man the sun maybe maybe
Galactic core and everybody like is a
piece of it we're all we are all stored
energy from the sun the sun blasts
energy it hits the Earth then that
energy has a chemical reaction which
converts into various things either
through heat or through you know
organisms that energy like the plants
absorb sunlight we consume the animals
consume the plants we consume the
animals and the plants it's all sunlight
being stored on earth have you looked
into remote viewing a little bit dude
that's apparent goats yeah the CIA is
like funding this stuff because it's
apparently real where you can see what's
I mean you can visualize what's
happening I don't know elsewhere
apparently I don't know but it's like
does that work I don't know it doesn't
make any sense logically but you can't
it's not real I mean you know when I was
part of the CIA I could only see the
future seven seconds out okay which is
more so what we were working on good for
sports though still live yeah
good for sports not really seven seconds
yeah it's good for you know some things
but like you can't even play roulette
you know where he's gonna throw the ball
though
it's good to avoid that's true crashes
yeah that's true uh I I wonder what is
the perception I used to think
perception was the way my brain
interprets the impulses but if you can
have perception without your brain or
maybe your your spirit is elsewhere I
think that you can have perception with
that okay I gotta read the Super Chat
real quick it's a little early but
Bobcat says the super chats you read are
generated by AI That's why you never
read mine when I tell you to read the
last Circle or small Wars Big Data I've
disproven your thesis boom science
anyway you were saying again
um that like your perception is maybe
your Consciousness is like your spirit
this warm ball of light that's moving
after people are experiencing you know
death or is that it can travel and
report back to your body data like
impulses and stuff so when someone asked
in the chat if I'm drunk no I have food
poisoning really bad that's why I'm
wearing a coat I have a fever
people like is he dying I'm like yes
probably slowly over the course of 80
years I had some yogurt that's all I ate
today bad food poisoning I it's getting
better I'm drinking coconut water but I
had some ginger ale to try and try and
help
but yeah is that is that real does that
work definitely made me feel better is
it a carbonation I don't know I just
felt way better maybe maybe it was
fluids and sugar and I hadn't eaten
anything and I was feeling really sick
and then it made me my stomach not hurt
and then I started feeling like I had
more energy because I almost was like I
don't think I can do the show man I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm sleeping but you
know head to ginger ale yeah when I was
feeling ill rather than just wait it out
and be like well I'll let this get out
of me it's better to repopulate the gut
with good stuff that's right that's why
I had the yogurt because you got to
replace that stuff and then you've got
to cultivate the good bacteria by not
eating heavy sugars and exercising you
know
what is it what is it called the the
spice or something
South Park to that episode
yeah that's from Dune yes well that is
the episode where they wanted was it Tom
Brady's feces because if you've got his
fecal bacteria and make you yeah it
would make you strong and fit fecal
implants man they do that that's a whole
like scientific path they take women or
anyone that's having like horrible gut
issues and they take feces from a
healthy person and put it up their butt
and the bacteria turns their gut healthy
yeah that's crazy son of a what's
going on it's all about it I don't know
man I think neurolink is gonna it's
gonna take over so rapidly people don't
understand a lot of people are like I
wouldn't do it yeah you say that but if
20 years ago we were like in 20 years
you're gonna put a CIA tracking device
in your pocket and you're gonna be happy
to do it they're like no I won't you're
crazy and now everybody has one like
well it's not so bad the the level of
convenience like how convenient life
becomes when you get neuralink is going
to be a considerable factor in how many
people actually we get it so if it if
you get neuralink and there's all kinds
of stuff that that your friends are
telling you oh this is so cool and blah
blah that will be a significant
motivator for people if it's not
functional and people are like ah
whatever you know you know if if that is
how people first perceive it or receive
it
um then I don't I don't see it taking
off oh no just read the superintendent
from Noah Sanders he says uh he was
hyped to get a new Beanie today but he
did get one's green it's only green for
today because it's St Patrick's Day and
he says Discord is busted it's not
busted but for some people there may be
some issues so I don't know if anybody
who's watching I'm in the Discord chat
right now yeah some VIP chat room what's
up dudes some people are having some
issues but if you want to join the the
chat become a member and hang out with
us we're I'm really excited for this
um and I think it'll be a great resource
for me especially when I'm doing stories
throughout the day like if someone's
like hey look at this story and I'm like
oh that's actually really interesting I
could do a segment about it so that'll
be fun hanging out in the VIP chat room
what what's your main like
um reticence about neural link
really toxic and it sounds like it's
bound to become part of life if it
really takes off to where there's going
to be like societal pressure
to to use it right like I just don't
there will be no choice yeah it's like
it'll be the whole conversation you're
gonna be like you're gonna be at home
and they're gonna call you like your
boss and they say hey we're having a
meeting in the metaverse you here yet
and you'll be like I don't have a neural
I could be like what do you mean you
don't have a neural link we're having a
meeting and people are already doing
meetings
and then you'll be like I never got to
be like well it's a requirement for this
job to be able to attend meetings and if
you can't we're gonna have to let you go
yeah and they're gonna be back I can go
get it tomorrow and they'll be like okay
well please do like not having a phone
like you can't coordinate with exactly
awesome what's your number I don't have
a cell phone well how much was it gonna
touch with you you can't okay I'm gonna
hire somebody else
that's what's going to happen people
don't realize it it's going to overnight
be ubiquitous there are people that
won't there are people that have to have
the right kind of phone to work like
there are people that you have to have
an apple to work with them because just
because of iMessage ah it's the worst
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel because I want all of
you to know that even when I am dying
from food poisoning I will be here to do
the show
um because I'm a workaholic and have
anxiety if I don't and I'm sitting there
in bed like covering sweat feverishing
just like but then there's been no show
today
foreign
well yeah I mean whoever was here I'm
like yeah I was thinking it's like it's
more so the people watching you know
it's like 30 000 people because for me
it was like oh it's just another night
but like for the guest it's kind of a
big deal to go be on a podcast that
you've never been on before no I'm
honored I'm honored well let's let's
read some of these super chats uh you
guys want to read some we got the
monitor you can read it yeah you want to
snag it let me see where I don't see any
of this where are they here we go
seem as I give you one question
potatoes for Sheamus uh shame as I give
you one potato happy average Awareness
Day Mr Coughlin more potatoes for you if
my guy Tim reads this for you he called
him see Miss Coughlin Sheamus is
steaming right now I'm sorry Sheamus
Sheamus Coughlin
goglin I'm gonna pull one up I don't
have access to that I can't use that oh
yeah uh let's see if I can find uh Mind
of a Madman said Jim sham Sheamus this
is funny Robert Bradbury said the
Republican party is now two-headed Hydra
with DeSantis and Trump they can't
figure out which head to cut off
yeah well if they do two more we'll come
back
Christina H says potato lies matter
um
William Walker says Tim you need garlic
for your food poisoning Studies have
shown it to be at least as beneficial as
penicillin for food poisoning say what I
love garlic maybe I just can't eat I
just I'll barf I was able to eat some
yogurt really helped yeah yeah it still
carries yogurt probiotics went right to
the fridge and I saw the c on it and I
was like it's mine now
garlic is a hundred times stronger than
antibiotics when it comes to killing
bacteria that cause food poisoning
according to Washington State University
wow I should put Garlic on everything
man I wonder if it's wrong Garlic's
awesome I will I will swallow two cloves
of garlic right now like pills it's the
diallyl sulfide apparently wow there's a
lot better than prescriptions typically
but this is according to one maybe I'll
maybe I'll I've got so much garlic at
home because I just chug garlic maybe
I'll just take a spoonful with the
medicine you know this says eating
Garlic after Contracting it probably
won't do much good but if you're stocked
up on the dial sulfide that maybe it'll
protect you so I don't know maybe it's a
bit of a preventative I'm feeling mostly
better like I was barfing and like the
past few hours I just feel like tired
and cold you know so I've been drinking
coconut water coming back vitamin C C
yeah just give a lot of vitamins you
need to make sure that you keep drinking
water too I think coconut water is
better well some something for fluids oh
yeah I'm drinking that too right now
coffee coconut water what a combo a
little peanut butter powder oh my God
it's the sweetness peanut butter powder
and coffee is good yeah yeah Jack
basobic turned me on to it hell yeah I
like PB uh that powder I'll show you I
have some downstairs it's fantastic adds
a creaminess to it it's good yeah and I
like peanuts so
let's grab another Super Chat big says
kafifi was a bad translation of an
Arabic expression for endurance in spite
of all the negative press we will endure
I don't think that's true
I don't believe that's true
it was it said despite all the negative
press confiti and I think what they were
trying to write was press coverage
and like if you believe that that's how
I thought he I thought he'd start my
coffee look it up no I yeah despite the
negative press confit that's all it said
something like that and like it's clear
they're trying to write press coverage
and then someone sausage fingered the
phone press send and went whoops is it
what did it say did you find it
six minutes yeah six minutes after
midnight on May 31st 2017 Trump tweeted
despite the constant negative press
kofifi
coverage and so people people were
saying that coffee meant I will stand
and so he was saying despite the
negative press I will stand and it's
like dude no no that's not what it was I
love that sorry
oh man I deleted the Tweet six hours
later yeah
it was intentional it became the biggest
story that's true I love it man
I'm really excited for uh I'm really
excited for like the the normal Trump
campaign stuff I'm really not excited
for the weird stuff that's gonna happen
you know deep fakes and you know
I'm extremely interested to find out
what kind of Impact deep fakes have if
there's going to be stuff that actually
moves the needle like where people get
you know uh fooled into something and it
actually has an impact on like polling
and stuff like that I'm extremely
interested to see that yeah that Mark
Twain quote that it's easier to fool
people than to convince them that
they've been fooled that's that's all
right Joe Biden says Discord has
devolved into nothing but Dad jokes
start over well maybe you gotta go to
the elite club hey the the elite VIP
golden club or whatever it's called
I'll be in there shortly too we just got
it set up last night and I haven't had
time because I woke up dying and I was
like we'll have it set up by tonight and
then I woke up dying and I was like
yeah and we still we still did the
culture War podcast with um
Sovereign bra and Mary Morgan it was
really fun and I was drinking coffee and
then as soon as we wrapped I like was
gonna faint I was dizzy I was like oh
man this is bad and I went to sleep just
went to sleep woke up at like six
probably just go to bed after this yeah
ruined my weekend you know I went to
Outback Steakhouse last night and now
I'm sick what's what's going on Outback
that was the only place I ate at did you
go out you didn't go after the show you
before the show the movie theater was
was shut down oh why we went to go see
Shazam
and the power was out in the theater oh
so they evacuated everybody oh and then
I was like let's go eat we were looking
on the map it's like there's an Outback
over here and we're like all right
Outback is good and I gotta admit it was
delicious
but if I could take it back I wouldn't
because it sucks but the food was just
really good had chicken tenders and
three three cheese steak dip Bloom and
onion and you know what the crazy thing
is I was I had this like feeling in my
mind I'm like I'm gonna get sick from
eating this oh you knew I just had but
it was like a gut feeling literally
right Dad joke you know wow but I was
like ah it'll be fine like what'll
probably happen is I'll feel sick at
night go to sleep wake up fine and then
I woke up like
head throbbing to full-on food poisoning
nuts
oh yeah search.com in the chat what's he
doing posting a bunch of pictures of me
all right what do we got Raymond g
Stanley Junior says OMG my favorite
graphene semantic loving authoritarian
pirate has his own Emoji thank you Lord
never fight an alligator underwater oh
okay thank you I was talking about Phil
for a second
all right what do we got
mad's Exton says Service guarantee
citizenship civilians live peacefully
but have limited rights
citizens get to vote and hold political
positions agreed
agreed this is a tough conundrum because
they really did landowners were the
voters because they were the only ones
that had like the skin in the game like
Phil said earlier and it was the only
way to identify someone as actually
being a part of the community yeah and
you know they care about their Community
because they're they're rooted and
that's very important when you're
deciding how the community functions if
you're just passing through and you get
a chance to change things that's kind of
crazy but the issue with service
guarantee citizenship is what if
leftists get control of the service you
know what if they start purging their
ideological enemies and then you say
something like I would like to serve and
they'll go well looks here like I'm
sorry you're disqualified for this
reason and everyone says no in Starship
Troopers anyone was allowed I'm like I'm
saying they'll make up excuses to excise
you so that they only have their
crackpot Communists with the ability to
vote to be fair that is that is the the
goal in mind it seems that is the goal
in of the of the left generally
yeah
all right leave me alone says a button
gives you one million dollars per press
but a random person dies would you press
it which polishing politician do you
think have effectively pressed it Trump
Biden I would not press it yeah I'm not
in the I'm not into that right now Bill
Gates probably pressed it a lot he's
sitting there being like this is working
my bank account's going up it's also
solving other problems for me
I could hear one from floating oh I
don't think anybody whose room would
press the button because we we have like
healthy and fulfilling lives you know
what I mean like a million dollars isn't
going to like I'll put it this way a
million dollars may make the average
person's life substantially better all
their costs are covered but like ripping
your soul in half well it's something
you can never come back from I don't
think I don't think people would do it I
think a lot of liberal types would do it
they'd be like I don't care it's one
person who cares if it's a random person
it might end up they'll say you or your
friend or something yeah and they'll be
like right that's the that's the The
Twilight Zone you press the button and
then your brother goes and dies you go
no I think I think that's actually a
toilet tone or no no yeah the monkey's
paw thing where the dude's like I wish I
had a million dollars I think it's a
phone call the monkey's finger goes down
and gets a phone call it's like your
father died he's left you everything
he's like no you know this wasn't worth
it yep got you the million dollars
though man I gotta hear one from
fleeting floating feathers uh Tim you
need to watch Obama's address to the UK
Parliament from 2011 where he says China
will be the ruling power of the world
and that the USA will Decline and have
to get them get used to them being so
wow that's first I've heard of that
they'll start buying you wand now invest
early
you know start buying Chinese Farmland
yeah start buying Chinese yeah but Trump
said I do gotta say that I am very
disappointed about the fake news
headline I thought that shimcast was
going to be real again but you you give
me my favorite legume instead it's sweet
potato legume I don't think so Sheamus
will be back uh it's so what you call it
it's um it's like a starchy vegetable
right yeah I forgot what's the word I
can't I'm too sick for this man what are
legumes anywhere are they beans they're
like uh they're like beans any plant
from uh it's um what's a What's the Word
[Music]
a tuber a tuber yes yeah root vegetable
and the leaves stems and pods are the
it's actually I think the funniest thing
that's a sweet potato too because like
we couldn't even respect Sheamus enough
to get a regular potato
that's all we got we were actually
looking for a puppet leprechaun we
couldn't find one so we ended up yeah it
was all Easter decorations it's not
Easter it's Saint Patty's Day what's
going on you know there's gotta be
leprechaun somewhere
but if we got one I was going to do an
Irish Sheamus thing like thanks for
having me on the show everybody like I'm
hopping yeah with a puppet but you know
we got a potato instead so oh Yuki yusui
asks if I want to write for Tim cast
free what do I do I don't think we can
legally take free writers
like yeah I don't think we can there's
there's uh liability issues stuff I
think the insurance would be like you
like lose your insurance or something a
lot of the super chats I've got access
to are the recent ones if there's any
older ones that you see
crack one out of the park whoa Amos
Moses says y'all should check out
Brandon herrera's video on the 50 BMG
pistol oh man speaking now look at that
Brandon's great
um you should get we should get Lucas
botkin from T-Rex arms to come on
there's he's he's he just was on uh
Tucker Carlson's Tucker Carlson today
the show the daytime show and he's only
he's only from uh he's from Tennessee oh
my God
50 BMG pistol from two days ago so the
ak-50 no that's old no he's I don't
think that he I don't think he's
actually achieved the the ak-50 yet I
think that's still a mean ak-50
because you know Brandon's the AK guy
and yeah and AKA 50. so if if anyone out
there knows if he's achieved the ak-50
how do you shoot a 50 BMG pistol I'm
watching the video right now it's a
breach loader it looks like I'm sure
it's miserable to shoot I shot a breach
loading 556 and it sucks to shoot like
oh it's got no it's a it's a pistol
how's it gonna how's he gonna do this
this is amazing what is it about the
breach load that makes it harder so the
breach load is just it's just a barrel
you put the bullet in and then close it
so there's a recoil there's no nothing
reciprocates you get all the recoil
right into your arm so with uh so like
my Barrett it's semi-automatic a portion
of the energy pulls the it pulls the
mechanism the hammer back or whatever no
I'm not gonna uh to reload the next
round so it's a spring-loaded thing that
absorbs a ton of the energy and then
pushes oh that's awesome there's a
spring that's how rifles work there's a
spring in the yeah what they call the
buffer tube there's a spring and there's
a what they call a buffer it's basically
a small weight inside the tube when the
gun goes off the bolt carrier group
slides back pulling the ground from the
spent cartridge from the chamber but
what pulls it back is the gas from the
explosion of the round wow so as the
bullets leaving there's High intense
there's some pressure and there's a tube
that the pressure pushes it shoving
that's extra P this is why humans are so
brilliant is using waste energy to
propel and then here's the best part if
you have uh what's it called like a
muzzle break it has uh slanted like
vents on the front so when it fires the
gas coming out pushes the gun forward
also reducing recoil there's and you can
get a bunch of different things you can
get a bunch of different things on your
for your what they call the muzzle
devices what he's talking about you can
get a muzzle brake which invents the gas
straight out that's so that way your
mouse stays flat you can get what they
call a bird cage which is in designed to
keep the black the fiery blast to a
minimum a muzzle break it looks like a
dragon shooting fire everywhere yeah
with a bird cage it keeps it like
redirects the energy yep so that
normally when you fire a rifle the
energy is going forward and backwards
with the muzzle brake the energy going
out then goes to the side so it removes
some of the energy coming The Recoil
coming back do the bullets hit harder
with a muzzle break no the bullets will
hit harder with a longer Barrel yeah
because they're spinning more accurately
no because you're you have the the
bullet going down the barrel there's
resistance because the bear the bullet
is actually just a little there's a
diminishing return on the length of a
barrel yeah so the the long but well it
is but with like a 556 you want to have
a round it was designed for a 20 inch
barrel
um so the gas is burning the entire time
that the bear that the round is going
down the barrel the gas is still burning
so the shorter the barrel the less time
that get the the
powder has to burn and the heat
propulsions lost to the air it's not so
much the heat it's it's pressure that
you're worried about so when we we fired
I think it was called like an rn52 or
something breach loading 50 BMG I was
the only one who didn't do it because
everybody was getting knocked back and
I'm like I'm just not like I'm not here
for that you know but when we got to
Bear it I fired the Barrett because the
semi-automatic the spring system it was
nothing like firing a 50 BMG Barrett
semi-auto felt nothing like I feel like
a 12 gauge charts more yeah 12 gauge
pump action is a lot of recoil right
into your shoulder so people that we got
we have shoulder pads for the for the
shotgun yeah with the 50 PMG we just you
know next spring it's a big spring in
that gun like I need that as a tiny
woman I like fall backwards well it's
for hunting helicopters
[Laughter]
perfect for the Border I want to ask you
about your weapon collection I don't
like outing people because it's like I
want everyone to think that everyone's
armed I don't want everyone to ever be
like no I don't have any weapons but do
you want to talk about that I mean give
me the thing I live in DC so yeah yes I
have pepper spray oh I don't even know
that's legal it's not oh geez
Mass genocide says yo Kellen where is
the onboarding channel in Discord
um the onboarding channel so you're
gonna get that once you interact with
beaniebot now I got a text from the tech
Ops that the Discord thinks beaniebot is
Spam which probably someone reported it
probably a troll reported it that's why
we have to do gating yep um now we're
the I know the tech teams working on
clarifying the instructions for anyone
that's having trouble in Discord so just
you know uh please be patient um we have
like two people working on it and
they're working all day so there's a lot
of different things but it should be
there it should be there and it depends
on your membership tier right so
um that's how you're going to determine
what you see in the server
all right Defender X says when you
mentioned the time loop I thought of
that Futurama episode plus Tim you
missed an opportunity to wear a green
beanie come on man
a green bean a green beanie I don't have
one I came with a girl it's a subtle
green shirt but I'm uh
yeah I got green pants on I got nothing
green I'm gonna wear my green jacket I
wasn't even thinking Tim was looking a
little green in the face when we shut up
that's true I was personally green so I
didn't think is everybody wearing some
kind of green Ian's not wearing green
green pants but they're like olive green
those are not green barely green okay
okay they actually do look green on
camera yeah they do but you're not
supposed to wear red oh that's that's
racist yeah I don't know where it comes
from but that's what I was told you know
we got to do a cast Castle bit now where
Sheamus shows up at the house and is
violently angry over this bit yeah
probably and then he like gets revenge
on everybody first Joe Biden and now you
I thought you were my friends
ah Shameless no please it was a joke
racism is no joke Tim Let's uh let's get
this fun fact from not Tim Burton says
fun fact sweet potatoes are in the
Morning Glory family really well
potatoes are in the nightshade family
with tomatoes peppers and eggplant
nightshades I hear that nightshades can
mute your
pineal gland or some crap like make
people like nightshades are toxic in
large doses yeah Tomatoes can kill you
they're like mind control substances
right maybe tomatoes so they say like
ketchup is a big part potatoes and
ketchup which is french fries and
ketchup it's a big like Attack of the
Killer Tomatoes
remember that The Nightshade you guys
wasn't that a movie or something
Tomatoes yeah the Mandrake you ever see
a mandrake root oh yeah it looks like a
human Harry Potter that screams and if
you hear it scream you die that's wild
apparently they're they're poisonous and
they look like men it's crazy there was
that dude who went into the wild and
they made that movie about it called
into the wild and then he ate the wrong
seeds and got real sick and then died
yeah
that was a different dude the uh the I'm
friends with bears guy that got them all
oh yeah his wife got eaten and he's on
video screaming oh they're eating us
like well yeah what's that called what's
that movie called it's Werner Herzog did
the movie on the bear Guy what's that
you got eaten yeah and his girlfriend
they both got devoured and you can hear
it yeah
I'm gonna jump off fight them off
oh what a horrible yeah and he he like
goes to the guy's mom or something he's
like don't I don't ever listen to this
audio she goes I won't burn her I won't
it's
so dumb Grizzly Man that's the name of
that documentary I still haven't seen it
here's a super chat from Omega 731 Tim
sorry for the related birthday gift
could not super chat in member mode but
here's enough for HBO Max for a month to
enjoy the series Babylon 5. since you
enjoy sg1 and Star Trek I feel you also
enjoy this series Battlestar Galactica
what season are you on
Galactica are you serious I watched that
10 years ago oh was it 10 years ago they
redid that it was longer than 10 years
ago omega's talking about Babylon five
have you seen it yet no I've seen only
passively some episodes I need to watch
it but um Battlestar Galactica is so
brilliant the philosophy survival you
know basically it's about humans create
AI the AI wipes out humanity and they
have these interplanetary colonies and
all that's left is like one small Fleet
of humans because everything's been
destroyed and the AI is tracking them
down trying to kill them and so that's
like and then there's politics like
there's a coal mining ship that recycles
raw materials for fuel and everyone who
works there as a slave so like because
they have to if you stop working we all
die is this like the future with the
Earth link whatever no I don't think
they're bad but like the officers live
in luxury and because they have to
they're in charge and then the poor
people in the mining ship are like I
can't work 18 hours a day every day I'd
rather die and they're like you can't
yeah you have to keep working and they
make kids do it and they start doing
they they finally have like a revolt and
it's like a rotation now where everyone
has to do it otherwise they died dude
that's a good show
well I don't want to spoil the ending
even though it is like a 13 year old
show yeah and it's based off a show from
the 70s did you ever see the original
yeah I mean I've seen some of the
original
Target sg1 I'm pretty sure at Joe
Rogan's new comedy club the stage of the
Stargate have you seen it is it really
yeah pretty sure the stages of Stargate
comedy Mothership yeah look up the
picture from uh Lex Friedman on
Instagram
and it's basically uh pretty sure the
stages of Stargate whoa I want to go it
just feels good watching them I mean
maybe we couldn't do an event there I
know I know we're not comedians but
maybe he would like Joe would let us oh
that'd be great yeah we're gonna be in
Austin on the 14th so I'm definitely
going to check it out if you want we can
get the AK guy to bring us to see if
we'll shoot his ak-50 he doesn't have it
done
but uh he's got parts for it Brandon I
wanted to get a um a nine millimeter
Makarov rifle yeah uh and it needs to be
custom built and like people have
offered to make it so if those don't
understand uh I don't know Makarov nine
millimeter rounds are Soviet they're
slightly shorter I believe than uh Luger
so they don't work in regular handguns
so I have a whole bunch of Soviet ammo I
would love to get you know dude I'm
looking for I'm looking at this image
from Lex Friedman about uh the Stars
Rogan stage is a Stargate it's lit up
but it's only half a star get the other
half's underground well I think he had
to make it distinct from a Stargate I
see so it's like you can kind of be like
that's a start again but he could always
be like no it's another star game it's a
UFO or something it's definitely half of
a portal it's a star game I wanna I
wanna see the other half
yeah because you know Joe watches good
shows or whatever what do you got Phil
you got a Super Chat uh let's see what I
don't know well it keeps moving let's
see um
okay hello my name is Dan uh MF from MF
Damien hell my name is Damian and I was
born at 706 6 minutes after 6 p.m I'm
not the Antichrist I'm just some a-hole
from a village Dad loved cool names and
noise nose candy saw the omen so here I
am I'm so glad that I selected that it's
super chat to read nothing like a super
chat referencing booger sugar booger
sugar here's one from uh sa federale
with a little bit of clarification
wearing red he says is British so that's
a one Ian uh also don't order black and
tans that's the Royal All-Star
constabulary nickname
was that like what are you supposed to
order an Irish car bomb those are
actually really good man I used to drink
it with Guinness with uh Bailey's a shot
of Bailey's that you drop in no no use
whiskey or something that's an Irish Car
Bomb Bailey's no I well the the the the
again with the with the Jameson and yeah
yeah that's what I thought Jameson yeah
James and then you got to drink it
really fast Kahlua is that what it is
called uh no you know it's Bailey's and
and Jameson James and then you drop the
shot into the glass yeah you gotta drink
it fast it starts to curdle yeah it's
super good dude Guinness is awesome I
don't really drink all that much but
again it's not its own it's the best
beer there's not a lot of booze that I
missed I missed car bombs those are good
they were so good is that racist I don't
no I don't think so horrific name I know
it's nice car bomb we've been this we've
been dissing The Irish all night long so
I don't think there's any reason to stop
dude there was a period where gen xers
and Boomers were pretty based I mean all
these offensive jokes and stuff I think
the Gen xers and Boomers basically are
probably pretty base they just don't
want to listen to the Millennials and
stuff cry it's just constant streaming
we gotta offer up as a government
program at communist Utopia
it'll be cheaper in the long run it'll
save your country say we're gonna fund
it I am willing to pay a premium tax to
create an island where all the
Communists can opt to go and when they
do opt it opt-in it's like a five-year
commitment and they can live under their
perfect socialist order and then we
don't have to worry about it I would
like Gen X to be louder if that's what
it takes I don't know I'm not into that
yeah I mean they were the Pepsi
Generations that's kind of not our deal
though my dad was like hey Ian I want to
start a show and I was like after he
made like some joke like off-color joke
I was like yeah probably not but then
after I said I was like no that's I want
him to make a show that was terrible
that I was afraid that for my father to
be canceled like what it's better he
makes a show than does it be funny if he
was like you know I want to do a show
like what about well I just plain don't
like Irish people like okay is that the
show's about you got it by the way if
you want to follow my dad on YouTube it
is cosmoinkus
c-o-s-m-o-i-n-k-u-s he's got some videos
from about 12 years ago playing guitar
the progenitor of Ian yeah I wonder what
that muscle they called him Cosmo when
he worked for the fire department I
don't think much of it as a kid but he's
out there that explains a lot yeah yeah
it was way before I smoked weed you guys
want to read some more super jets I do I
do here we go you want to read that one
Phil
uh from
roll them proper Bill Gates owns patent
zero six zero six zero six and its
purpose lines up with the Bible's
prediction oh yeah it's a patent for
tracking body functions to Grant you
access to a cryptocurrency okay and its
number is 666 like come on man when he
got that patent if he really if it was
really an accident he'd be like what the
he's like I don't change this are you
crazy people are gonna come in no he was
like is it cool no this is cool I want
to read this Super Chat because it's a
it's a relatively large one uh it's from
get a pair with Sully I don't really
understand it but I'm gonna read it it
says we lost in Committee Against the
Minnesota Dems anti-third party Bill we
convinced enough Dems to vote no so the
Dem chairman decided to lay the bill
over into Omnibus spending Bill wow no
more debate no chance for veto now it's
time to work twice as hard
dude the system just doesn't exist
anymore Democrats are just like we can
do whatever we want no one will do
anything about it Biden you had Cuomo
during the lockdown Supreme Court says
you can't shut down churches he goes
okay I'll just make a new order sue me
over that one and then what has to
happen is you got assume over the New
Order then when the court tracks it down
he'll then shut down again with a new
order and he'll be like yeah this order
got you know countered but what about
this one
they just do whatever they want there's
no repercussions
I think
it's wild it's all coming crash you know
we we should really get Lucas bucking on
because we could talk about he's he's uh
he's got a lot of insight into like
civilian
Firearms ownership and and
Communications and
extracurricular activities uniforms and
stuff you know what I want to do I want
to get a
um
Christian prophecy scholar for the
culture War at some point badass I
wonder if um
we'll just talk about it well not Prager
I mean
I'm talking about some dude who's like
the like that guy from Angels and Demons
or The Da Vinci Code you know like a Tom
Hanks type guy who's like I have tracked
the kite's temple I know all the
revelations and like Donald Trump and
I'll be like whoa because it was fun it
was fun hanging out with Sovereign Brock
because he was like look at this and I
pulled it up and I was like whoa about
the Antichrist yeah about Donald Trump
the Twitter account is Donnie darkened
it's important because even if there
isn't an antichrist it's important that
people don't freak out that's the most
important thing whether it's real or not
stay calm I'll tell you what I'm free if
it I don't Tech I don't tend to believe
in the Antichrist if the Antichrist
turns out to be real that will be at
least slightly on the freaky side the
upside is apparently uh the return of
Christ overrides the Antichrist and
brings peace to the world if you believe
in Christ if you you know whatever all
right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button so I can go to
bed and I have Luke got me out of those
beds that heat up so I'm gonna blast the
heat because I got a fever and just like
watch scary movies
and then probably have no weekend
because I ate garbage food from a
garbage place so but smash the like
button become a member at timcast.com
the Discord server is up there are some
issues but working through it it
literally just went live and you can
hang out and chat 24 7 in the Discord
server we do have rules because the
purpose of the server is not a
free-for-all open space of saying
whatever you want it's literally to
track current events have discussion
about the ideas and share I share ideas
in a deck an academic way simply put
that's what we try to do on the show in
as it is we try not to be like I don't
know two just aggressive or nasty we
want to make sure that our ideas are
actually backed by sound arguments and
we also don't want to get banned so that
means we got to watch out for people who
are intentionally going in to try and
sabotage it because we want to create a
community so anyway become a member and
uh smash the like button all that stuff
Jenny do you want to shout anything out
sure thank you for having me first of
all and you can follow me on Twitter at
jennyster
right on how are you Phil I am Phil
Labonte the lead singer of All That
Remains you can follow me on Twitter at
Phil that remains uh on Instagram I am
Phil that remains official yeah thanks
for your expertise On the Border that
was awesome good to see you uh I'm Ian
Crossland follow me anywhere at Ian
Crossland also check out pop culture
crisis I was on today with Dane font
Mary Morgan and Brett dasovic it was
fantastic uh here's to many more and
real quick check out Mary Morgan on the
whatever podcast because she was like
roasting these
thoughts she's with the kids call based
yeah that was fine anyway Kellen uh
Kellen uh Kellen PDL Ian I second that I
think Phil myself You Are all uh
recurring guests on pop culture from
time to time so we have fun there
um and Sheamus
that's a really good point man you know
I've I've actually I've never actually
considered that yeah but the in the
accent insults me
that's that's fair too you know what
let's get him out of here all right
everybody thanks for hanging out and we
will see you all next time